Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. cash on hand to grow with up to 55 interest-free days. Redefine possible with Business Platinum. That's the powerful backing of American Express. Terms and conditions apply. Visit amex.ca business platinum. On the quarter deck of his flagship, The Victory, a small, slender figure gazed out at the horizon. He wore a smart blue coat with gold-embroidered decorations and a dark cocked hat. He had only one arm, and if you looked closely, you might have noticed that his right eye was dull and sightless.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告版本、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。手头现金充裕，享受长达 55 天的免息期，助您实现业务增长。使用 Business Platinum 重新定义可能。这是美国运通公司提供的强大后盾。需遵守相关条款与条件。请访问 amex.ca/businessplatinum。在他的旗舰“胜利号”的后甲板上，一个身材瘦小的身影眺望着地平线。他穿着一件剪裁得体的蓝色外套，上面有金线刺绣的装饰，头戴一顶深色的三角帽。他只有一只手臂，如果你仔细看，你可能会注意到他的右眼灰暗无神。
All his life he had waited for this moment. Growing up in a sleepy village at the edge of England, he had always loved stories of the sea. He had joined the Royal Navy when he was twelve, sailing to the Arctic, the Caribbean, India and North America. He had won fame and honor in battle after battle, losing an arm and the sight in one eye, and becoming one of the most famous men in the world. But this was the supreme challenge, the hour of destiny, a single titanic showdown to decide the mastery
他一生都在等待这一刻。他在英格兰边缘的一个宁静村庄长大，一直都很喜欢大海的故事。他十二岁时加入了英国皇家海军，航行到过北极、加勒比海、印度和北美。他在一场又一场的战斗中赢得了名誉和荣誉，失去了一臂和一只眼睛，并成为了世界上最著名的人物之一。但这是终极挑战，是命运的时刻，是一场决定谁能统领
of the seas once and for all. He nodded to one of his lieutenants. A moment later the first of thirty-one little flags began to climb up the masts, sending a signal to the rest of the fleet. England expects that every man will do his duty. And on ship after ship, men began to cheer, raising their voices, shaking their fists in the air, their hearts pounding with passion and pride. Now more than ever, they were ready.
海洋的单一决战，从此一劳永逸。他向其中一位中尉点了点头。片刻之后，三十一面小旗子中的第一面开始升上桅杆，向舰队的其他船只发送信号。英国期望每个人都尽职尽责。在每一艘船上，人们开始欢呼，高声呐喊，在空中挥舞着拳头，他们的心中充满了激情和骄傲。现在比以往任何时候都更加准备就绪。
And Dominic, after that reading, my heart too is pounding with passion and pride, because that is the opening of your new book aimed at children, but a brilliant read that I think would be hugely enjoyed by all patriotic British adults as well. Nelson, Hero of the Seas. And you've described as a new life and times of Britain's greatest hero out now for readers of all ages. All ages, Tom.
多米尼克，听了那段朗读后，我的心也充满了激情和骄傲，因为那是你为儿童创作的新书的开篇，但这是一本精彩的读物，我认为所有爱国的英国成年人也会非常喜欢。纳尔逊：海洋英雄。你将其描述为英国最伟大英雄的新生活与时代，现已面向所有年龄段的读者发行。所有年龄段，汤姆。
All ages. And I think Nelson is Britain's greatest hero. Yes, yes, I agree with you. I think he's one of the most exceptional leaders that Britain ever produced. I know Lord Byron called him famously Britannia's God of War. You think there's a different dimension to Nelson's character? And it goes back to this word hero, the heroes of the classical world. So he's Britain's answer, I suppose, indeed, to these kind of mythic characters who embody something much bigger than themselves. Well, people may remember that we did an episode on Trafalgar about three years ago. And in
所有年龄段。我认为纳尔逊是英国最伟大的英雄。是的，是的，我同意你的看法。我认为他是英国历史上最杰出的领袖之一。我知道拜伦勋爵曾著名地称他为“不列颠的战神”。你认为纳尔逊的性格中还有另一个维度吗？这就回到了“英雄”这个词，古典世界的英雄。所以我想，他确实是不列颠对这种体现了远超自身之物的神话人物的回应。人们可能还记得，大约三年前我们做过一期关于特拉法加海战的节目。在那期节目中，
that I suggested that Nelson is kind of hero in the classical sense. Classical heroes were terrible. And there's no question that Nelson is a great of hero in the classical sense. Classical heroes were terrible. And there's no question that Nelson is a great leader because he does inspire his men to fight and of course to kill with a terrifying sense of unbridled passion. And in a way that seemed to Britain's enemies on the sea, most notably the French, something kind of almost more than human. And Adam Nicholson, who wrote a brilliant book on Trafalgar, he described the Royal Navy under Nelson as the most effective maritime killing machine in the world.
我提出纳尔逊在古典意义上是一种英雄。古典英雄都很可怕。毫无疑问，纳尔逊在古典意义上是一位伟大的英雄。古典英雄都很可怕。毫无疑问，纳尔逊是一位伟大的领袖，因为他确实激励他的手下战斗，当然也带着一种令人毛骨悚然的、无拘无束的激情去杀敌。在某种程度上，在英国的海上敌人（最著名的是法国人）眼中，这几乎超越了人类的极限。亚当·尼科尔森写过一本关于特拉法加海战的精彩著作，他将纳尔逊指挥下的英国皇家海军描述为世界上最高效的海上杀戮机器。
And there is something lethal about him in the way that there was say about Henry V, who we did series on earlier. But he is also very much a Christian hero. Nelson did not enjoy war for war's sake. And everyone who knows about Nelson, the one thing that they'll probably remember is that his dying phrase is, kiss me Hardy, and we creatures and often lamented the cruel necessity of it. But it was a principle of duty, which all men owed their country in defense of her laws and liberty. And in that duty, his record of achievement, when you come up close to it, it's just amazing. I mean, just stunning victory after stunning victory and it matters. I mean, vastly more than Henry the fifth's victory, which leads to nothing. Nelson's victories.
他身上有一种致命的特质，就像我们之前做过系列的亨利五世一样。但他同样是一位名副其实的基督教英雄。纳尔逊并不为了战争本身而享受战争。每个了解纳尔逊的人，大概都会记住他临终前的一句话是：“吻我，哈迪”，而我们这些凡人常常为战争的残酷必要性感到痛惜。但这是一种责任原则，是所有人为了捍卫国家法律和自由而对祖国负有的责任。在这项责任上，当你仔细审视他的成就记录时，简直令人惊叹。我的意思是，一场又一场惊人的胜利接踵而至，而且意义重大。我的意思是，这比亨利五世毫无结果的胜利要重要得多。纳尔逊的胜利，
I mean, they secure Britain from invasion and by establishing the supremacy of the Royal Navy, which endures basically for a century, I mean, maybe even more than that, it's what enables the British empire to become the global power that it does. enables the British Empire to become the global power that it does. It essentially provides the global shield for the process of making the world a single kind of polity. Yeah, globalisation. Globalisation. People may feel that all of these things are bad things, but also, for instance, it enables the abolitionists to use the Navy to destroy the slave trade. For good and bad, he's an incredibly momentous
我的意思是，它们保护了英国免受入侵，并通过确立英国皇家海军的霸权地位——这种霸权基本上持续了一个世纪，甚至可能更久——使得英国帝国能够成为它后来那样的全球大国。使得英国帝国能够成为它后来那样的全球大国。它基本上为将世界融合成单一政体的进程提供了全球保护伞。是的，全球化。全球化。人们可能会觉得所有这些事情都是坏事，但例如，这也使废奴主义者能够利用海军来摧毁奴隶贸易。无论好坏，他都是一个具有极其重大意义的
figure and I think absolutely worth revisiting, even if you hadn't done a book about him. And also, of course, it provides an interesting counterpoint to what we're doing in the French Revolution because Nelson defines himself very much against the revolution. It definitely does. And I think it's important to say he's not just a killing machine. He's a subtle diplomat. Even when he's not fighting, he is a brilliant manager of men. I mean, he's a brilliant embodiment actually of bigger things. We haven't done much in the rest of history about 18th century Britain, the century in which Britain actually became the most modern country in the world, an industrial superpower. So that he,
人物，我认为绝对值得重新审视，即使你没有写过关于他的书。当然，这也为我们正在进行的法国大革命的研究提供了一个有趣的对照，因为纳尔逊非常明确地将自己定义为大革命的对立面。确实如此。我认为必须指出的是，他不仅仅是一台杀戮机器。他是一位老练的外交官。即使在不战斗的时候，他也是一位杰出的人员管理者。我的意思是，他实际上是更宏大事务的杰出化身。在《历史的 rest》中，我们没有过多涉及18世纪的英国，那个英国实际上成为世界上最现代化的国家、工业超级大国的世纪。因此我认为，
I think, is a brilliant window into the story of, you know, British parliamentary government, the sinews of finance, the story of imperial expansion, we'll obviously touch on the slave trade, but also everything that he achieves. What makes it such a great story is it's a combination of his individual genius, and I don't think genius is too strong a word, with the structures of finance, bureaucracy. And the industrial revolution. Yeah. Beyond that, this world of canals and turnpikes and mills and manufacturers, that has enabled
他是了解英国议会政府的故事、金融的骨髓、帝国扩张的故事的一个绝佳窗口，我们显然会触及奴隶贸易，还有他所取得的一切成就。使它成为如此伟大故事的原因，是他的个人天才（我认为天才这个词并不过分）与金融、官僚体制结构的结合。以及工业革命。是的。除此之外，运河、收费公路、磨坊和制造商构成的这个世界，使得
Britain already in the Seven Years' War, and then will do again in the Napoleonic Wars, to overturn centuries of French hegemony and Britain to step forward as the kind of handmaiden of modernisation in the world. Yeah. I mean, I think he is the human embodiment of everything that is making Britain the great power that it becomes in the 19th century. And that's why it's so telling that Hitler's plan for the occupation of Britain, if he'd secured it, would be to remove the great column of Nelson in the aptly named Trafalgar Square and take it to Berlin. Nelson in a way is the embodiment of Britain's sense of its own greatness in the 19th century.
英国已经在七年战争中，并且将在拿破仑战争中再次做到这一点：推翻了几个世纪以来的法国霸权，使英国作为世界现代化的某种侍女大步向前。是的。我的意思是，我认为他是使英国成为19世纪伟大强国的一切事物的化身。正因如此，希特勒占领英国的计划（如果他成功的话）非常说明问题：那就是拆除恰如其分地命名为特拉法加广场上的纳尔逊纪念柱，并把它运到柏林。在某种程度上，纳尔逊正是英国在19世纪对其自身伟大感到的化身。
But the other thing about Nelson that makes him such an appealing subject is that as well as being this remarkable naval leader, he's a very human figure. I find him quite a lovable figure, but he's also quite a comical figure at times. He is. His love life is often hilarious. It's colourful to say the least, isn't it? He has a tremendous sense of his own uniqueness and his own exceptionalism. He has a star quality. He believes himself to be a star.
但纳尔逊身上另一个让他如此吸引人的地方在于，除了这位杰出的海军领袖，他还是一个非常人性化的人物。我发现他是一个相当可爱的人物，但有时他也是一个相当滑稽的人物。他的确如此。他的感情生活经常令人捧腹。至少可以说是多姿多彩的，不是吗？他对自己的独特性和例外主义有着非凡的自我意识。他有一种明星气质。他坚信自己就是一颗明星。
And of course that can be incredibly exciting and inspirational, but it can, as you say, also be quite funny. Perhaps if I was being incredibly harsh, I would say there are moments of slight David Brent behaviour from Nelson. When those medals seem to clank a bit too much. Yeah, exactly. So let's get into his story and Theo has this under very, very strict instructions because as a Frenchman, he is terrified that this will balloon into a 20-part series. You know, the Battle of Cape St. Vincent, the second 20 minutes. Anyway, we talked about the sense of immense flux, immense
当然，这可能令人无比兴奋和振奋，但正如你所说，有时也相当滑稽。或许，如果我要刻薄一点的话，我会说纳尔逊身上有时会有那么一点大卫·布伦特式的行为。当那些勋章看起来叮当作响得有点过头的时候。是的，完全如此。那么让我们进入他的故事吧。西奥对此有着非常、非常严格的指令，因为作为一个法国人，他非常害怕这会膨胀成一个二十集的系列剧。（你知道的，圣文森特角战役，第二部分花二十分钟。）无论如何，我们讨论了18世纪那种巨大的变迁、
change and progress and excitement in the 18th century. But Nelson is born into a part of the world that actually is very sleepy. He's born in Norfolk, Burnham Thorpe, in September 1758. He's not that far from the sea, a couple of hours walk. If he'd walked down to the sea as a little boy, he would have heard sailors speaking Dutch or German or whatever. So it is-
巨大的变化、进步和兴奋感。但纳尔逊出生的世界实际上非常沉睡。他于1758年9月出生在诺福克的伯纳姆索普。离大海并不算远，步行几个小时就到了。如果他小时候走到海边，他会听到水手们说荷兰语、德语或其他语言。所以这是一个——
Had a broad horizons. Yes. It's both kind of deep England, but it's connected to the rest of Europe. It's a world in which most people, of course, are farm laborers. Very few in that part of Norfolk can read and write. His father is the local vicar. So his father is the Reverend Edmund Nelson.
视野开阔的地方。是的。它既有一种深厚英格兰的底色，又与欧洲其他地方相连。在这个世界里，大多数人当然都是农场劳动力。诺福克那个地方很少有人识字。他的父亲是当地的牧师。所以他的父亲是埃德蒙·纳尔逊牧师。
And I think the Reverend Edmund Nelson is quite a sweet character, isn't he? I mean, the weird thing about Nelson is he gets this incredible drive and fighting spirit from somewhere, but he definitely doesn't get it from Edmund. Because Edmund. No. Because Edmund just likes, you know, curling up with an improving book or sitting by the fire and musing on times gone by. Yes, toasting a slice of bread. Exactly.
我认为埃德蒙·纳尔逊牧师是一个相当可爱的人物，不是吗？我的意思是，关于纳尔逊奇怪的地方在于，他不知从哪里获得了这种不可思议的动力和战斗精神，但他绝对不是从埃德蒙那里继承的。因为埃德蒙。不。因为埃德蒙只喜欢，你知道的，蜷缩着读一本有教益的书，或者坐在火炉旁，沉思逝去的岁月。是的，烤一片面包。正是如此。
With his toasting fork. I mean, but I guess one thing that he does get from his father, who is ministering to people who are often illiterate, I guess, and quite poor, is that Nelson picks up a very hierarchical sense of how society should be ordered. In which those who are well-off, which would include of course the vicar, but local squires as well, are owed obedience and deference by the poor, but equally the poor can expect to be treated well by the well- off. So it's, I suppose, a kind of very paternalistic sense of hierarchy.
用他的烤面包叉。我的意思是，不过我想他从他父亲那里继承的一点是——他的父亲经常向那些往往目不识丁、相当贫穷的人们传教——纳尔逊从中领悟到了一种关于社会应该如何建立的非常森严的等级观念。在这个观念中，富裕的人（当然包括牧师，还有当地的乡绅）理应得到穷人的服从和敬意，但同样，穷人也可以指望受到富人的善待。所以我想，这是一种非常家长式的等级观念。
Yeah, absolutely. And this of course is exactly what Nelson will find on the ships of the Royal Navy. A stern but kindly father. Exactly. I think that's how he thinks a captain should be. But a captain, you know, like a squire, should look out for those below him. Yes, absolutely. And Nelson is absolutely wedded to this concept and it's what makes him very loved.
是的，绝对是这样。当然，这正是纳尔逊在英国皇家海军的舰艇上所发现的。一位严厉但慈爱的父亲。没错。我想这就是他认为一个船长应该有的样子。但船长，你知道的，就像乡绅一样，应该照顾他下面的人。是的，完全如此。纳尔逊绝对笃信这个概念，这也是他深得人心的原因。
His men know this, absolutely, love him for it. So Nelson's mother, Catherine Suckling, she was related sort of slightly distantly to the Walpole family, great family, Sir Robert Walpole. So they do have family connections. They have 11 children, Horatio is the sixth. His mother died when he was nine on Boxing Day 1767 and she left him one great legacy which listeners will be delighted to hear was an intense suspicion of the French So Nelson once told a friend. He said I'll never have a Frenchman on board my ship except as a prisoner I put no confidence in them forgive me, but my mother hated the French
他的手下非常清楚这一点，绝对因此而爱戴他。所以纳尔逊的母亲，凯瑟琳·萨克灵，她与沃波尔家族（显赫的家族，罗伯特·沃波尔爵士）有着某种远亲关系。所以他们确实有家族背景。他们有11个孩子，霍雷肖是第六个。1767年圣诞节后的第二天，也就是他九岁时，他的母亲去世了。母亲给他留下了一份伟大的遗产，听众们听到这里一定会感到高兴，那就是对法国人强烈的猜忌。所以纳尔逊曾对一个朋友说。他说，我绝不会让法国人上我的船，除非他们是俘虏。我绝不信任他们。请原谅我，但我的母亲讨厌法国人。
So I don't know where his mother got this from. Yeah, where she got that from. Just the general culture of the 18th century, I suppose, Tom. And his mother was just a very good judge. Well, I suppose that France is the great enemy for Britain even before the revolutionary period. You know, it's the great rival in the Seven Years' War. Exactly. And it's the traditional enemy, isn't it?
所以我不知道他的母亲是从哪里学来这一点的。是的，她是从哪里弄来这种观念的。我想，大概只是18世纪的总体文化氛围吧，汤姆。而且他的母亲只是一个非常明智的人。嗯，我想，甚至在大革命时期之前，法国就是英国的巨大敌人。你知道的，它是七年战争中的巨大对手。没错。而且它是传统的敌人，不是吗？
It is. In a sense, an Englishwoman does France honor by hating it, you might say. Right. It's respect. It's respect. It's the respect for a fearsome and sinister adversary, but one at your level. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, she's not bothering to hate the Dutch, say, or the Danes. No, no, no. No one cares about them. So the Reverend Nelson is now a single parent from 1767 and he needs to find places for all his children. So an older brother goes off to the tax office,
确实如此。从某种意义上说，一个英国女性通过痛恨法国来赋予法国荣誉，你可以这么说。对的。这是一种尊重。这是一种尊重。是对一个可怕而阴险的对手的尊重，但这个对手与你处于同一水平。是的。是的。我的意思是，她才懒得去恨荷兰人或者丹麦人呢。不，不，不。没人关心他们。所以埃德蒙·纳尔逊牧师从1767年起成了单亲父亲，他需要为他所有的孩子找到安身之所。因此，一个较大的哥哥去了税务局，
the girls, he finds work in local haberdasher's and things like that. But he sends Horatio and his brother William away to boarding school. First of all, they went to a school in Norwich, then they went to a school called Pate's Grammar School. And later on in Nelson's life, there were a whole load of anecdotes told about his school days, which were made up. Yeah, it's kind of stuff from Plutarch, isn't it? Exactly. But my favorite one, which I guess possibly has the ring of truth. They were in the dorm apparently one night and they were all talking about these pears that were growing on the trees in Frogger Jones' garden. And Nelson said, oh, to the older boys,
女儿们，他在当地的男服女帽店之类的地方给她们找了工作。但他把霍雷肖和他的弟弟威廉送去了寄宿学校。首先，他们去了一所诺维奇的学校，然后他们去了一所叫佩特文法学校的学校。在纳尔逊后来的生活中，流传着大量关于他学校生活的轶事，这些都是虚构出来的。是的，这有点像普鲁塔克笔下的那种故事，不是吗？完全如此。但我最喜欢的一个故事，我猜可能带有几分真实色彩。有一天晚上，他们显然在宿舍里，大家都在谈论弗罗格·琼斯花园树上结的那些梨。纳尔逊对大一点的男孩们说：哦，
you don't have the guts to go and get them. I'll get them. And he climbed out of the window, got all these pears, climbed back up to the window and then distributed them, but he didn't keep any for himself. And the boy said, why don't you want them? And he said, I don't actually like pears. I only took them because the rest of you were afraid. So you see, I mean, it doesn't really matter if that's true or not, because it is true, obviously, to his character. Exactly. Which he will display later in life in which courage is the absolute leitmotif of his achievements. So it is kind of
你们没有胆量去把它们摘下来。我去摘。于是他爬出窗户，摘了所有这些梨，又爬回窗户，然后把它们分发出去，但自己一个也没留。大一点的男孩问：你为什么不要它们？他说：我其实根本不喜欢梨。我拿它们只是因为你们其他人都害怕。所以你看，我的意思是，这是否属实其实并不重要，因为它显然符合他的性格。正是如此。他在后来的生活中将展现出这一点，勇气绝对是他所有成就的主旋律。所以从某种意义上说，这确实很
Plutarchian in that sense. There is no possible way that you can undervalue Nelson's physical courage. His physical courage is extraordinary. No, unbelievable. Yeah. The other thing he obviously took from his school days and we can know this from his letters and whatnot is he clearly did like Shakespeare and he liked in particular Henry V because he is clearly obsessed by the band of brothers speech because he refers to it again and again. We few, we happy few, we band of brothers. And I think that that speaks to, that gives you a little sense of the sort of romantic
具普鲁塔克式的风格。你绝不可能低估纳尔逊的身体勇气。他的身体勇气非同寻常。不，难以置信。是的。另一件他显然从学校生活中带走的东西——我们可以从他的信件等资料中得知这一点——是他显然很喜欢莎士比亚，他尤其喜欢《亨利五世》，因为他显然对“兄弟连”的演讲着迷不已，他一次又一次地引用它。我们少数几个人，我们这幸运的少数人，我们兄弟连。我认为这说明了，这让你对他的那种浪漫主义
yearnings I think that he has. But also again, that kind of sense of paternalism because Henry the fifth speech refers to people being gentled by that sense of brotherhood. It doesn't matter how mean you are. And Nelson is very, very keen on that. He's very keen on helping people rise above what other people might have thought was their station. And it will benefit Nelson himself who will end up a peer of the realm. Absolutely it would. Yes. I mean, that's the essence of his leadership, isn't it? The Band of Brothers idea. Yeah.
向往有了一点点体会。但同样，这也体现在那种家长式的作风上，因为亨利五世的演讲提到了人们被这种兄弟情谊所感化。不管你多么卑微。纳尔逊对这一点非常、非常热衷。他非常热衷于帮助人们超越他人可能认为属于他们的社会地位。这也将使纳尔逊本人受益，他最终将成为王国的贵族。绝对会的。是的。我的意思是，这就是他领导力的精髓，不是吗？兄弟连的理念。是的。
So when he's 12, his father, they must have read in the newspapers or heard talk of a crisis brewing in of all places, the Falkland Islands. I'm heard of. Where there's very bad behavior from Spanish speakers, not for the first time or the last time. No. Who are trying to wrest control of these very clearly British islands. What are they thinking? They hear that his uncle, so this is Catherine Suckling's brother, Morris, is going to sea. He's an experienced Royal Navy officer and he's taking a ship called a Raisonable to
所以当他12岁时，他的父亲——他们一定在报纸上读到过，或者听到人们议论——在福克兰群岛这个意想不到的地方正在酝酿一场危机。前所未闻。西班牙语使用者在那里表现得非常糟糕，这已经不是第一次也不是最后一次了。不。他们正试图从这些很明显是英国的岛屿手中夺取控制权。他们在想什么？他们听说他的叔叔（也就是凯瑟琳·萨克灵的弟弟莫里斯）要出海了。他是一位经验丰富的英国皇家海军军官，正准备指挥一艘名为“理智号”（Raisonable）的
sea. And the Nelsons use this as an opportunity to say, could you take Horatio with you? You know, this would be a great start for Horatio. And it makes sense, the Navy, right? Because he's obviously not got the personality of a clergyman that much as clear if he's climbing out of windows and... Yeah, and nicking pears. ...stealing pears. You don't have that in the Church of England.
船出海。纳尔逊一家利用这个机会说：你能把霍雷肖带上吗？你知道，这对于霍雷肖来说会是一个很好的开端。这很合情理，海军对吧？因为很明显，如果他会爬窗户……是的，还有偷梨……偷梨的话，他显然没有当牧师的个性。你在英国国教会里是不会有这种行为的。
The army was very expensive to buy a commission in the army, but the Navy is different. The only things that Edmund, the vicar, needs to pay for really are his uniform and his sea chest and a little bit of kit and then off he goes because the Navy is more meritocratic than the army. Yeah, but also it's just sufficiently open to nepotism. Exactly. That it will benefit Nelson. So as a person who's not going to be an able seaman you join as a midshipman, don't you? Yes, you do. This is kind of like a trainee officer and you're not really allowed to join the Navy
在陆军中，买一个军官职位要花很多钱，但海军则不同。埃德蒙牧师只需要为他支付制服、海员箱和一点随身装备的费用，然后他就可以出发了，因为海军比陆军更具精英统治色彩。是的，但它同时也足够开放，允许裙带关系的存在。正是如此，这会让纳尔逊受益。作为一个不会成为普通水手的人，你作为见习军官加入，不是吗？是的，确实如此。这有点像培训中的军官，在你13岁
until you're 13. But Nelson gets in at the age of 12 because Morris Suckling pulls strings for him. And it's that blend of meritocracy and nepotism suits Nelson to the ground. It does indeed. Absolutely it does. So Morris actually at first says, why poor Horatio? Why Horatio? Why he that is so weak that he above all the rest should be sent to rough it out at sea?
之前，其实是不允许加入海军的。但纳尔逊在12岁时就加入了，因为莫里斯·萨克灵为他走了后门。正是精英统治与裙带关系的这种结合，极大地适合了纳尔逊。确实如此，完全如此。所以莫里斯起初说：为什么要可怜的霍雷肖？为什么是霍雷肖？为什么这个如此虚弱、最不应该被送到海上经受艰难困苦的人偏偏是他？
And that actually expresses something that is a theme throughout Nelson's career. People are always astonished when they see him. Well, he's very slight, isn't he? And he's very sickly. He actually gets seasick and he's always got headaches and stomach problems and all of this kind of thing. He's got a great mop of hair that seems to weigh him down. I mean, he looks like a schoolchild until quite later, you know, in his teens. Absolutely he does. And actually Morris says, well, the first time we go into action, a cannonball may knock off his head and provide
这其实表达了贯穿纳尔逊整个职业生涯的一个主题。人们每次看到他时总是感到惊讶。嗯，他非常瘦弱，不是吗？而且他非常多病。他其实会晕船，而且总是头痛、胃部有问题以及诸如此类的事情。他有一头浓密的头发，似乎压得他喘不过气来。我的意思是，直到他十几岁的后期，他看起来都还像个小学生。他绝对是这样的。事实上莫里斯说：好吧，我们第一次投入战斗时，一颗炮弹可能会轰掉他的脑袋，
for him at once, but I'll take him. Yeah. And so he packs up his trunk and goes off and Dominic, where does he head to, to join the Navy and embark on his adventures at sea? I hope you're not going to bring this up every time this place recurs in the story. This is the one time you're allowed to say it. He goes to Chatham, which is Tom's favorite place. He goes to Chatham by coach. And yes, we will one day do a podcast all about Chatham by coach and yes, we will one day do a podcast all about Chatham as Tom and the Chatham tourist board desperately are hoping. So he goes down to Chatham, which is the great dockyard. Chatham is the epitome of modernity, I guess, isn't it? With its rope works and its kind of the systems for building the ships and providing for the ships and repairing them and all of that
从而立刻了结他，但我还是带上他吧。是的。于是他收拾好行李出发了，多米尼克，他前往哪里加入海军并开始他的海上冒险之旅呢？我希望你不要每次这个地方在故事中出现时都提起这个。这是你唯一一次被允许说出来的机会。他去了查塔姆，那是汤姆最喜欢的地方。他坐马车去了查塔姆。是的，总有一天我们会做一期关于坐马车去查塔姆的播客，是的，正如汤姆和查塔姆旅游局热切期望的那样，总有一天我们会做一期关于查塔姆的播客。所以他去了查塔姆，那是伟大的造船厂。查塔姆可以说是现代性的缩样，我猜，不是吗？凭借其绳索厂以及建造船只、为船只提供物资、修理船只的各种系统以及所有这
kind of thing. Yeah, I always remember a phrase that I picked up when I read Neymar Roger, who's the great historian of the Royal Navy, when we did our episode on Trafalgar. He said that the naval establishments represented in many respects, so many islands of the 19th century in the 18th century countryside, that a place like Chatham or Portsmouth, that this is the cutting edge of technology and industrialisation anywhere in the world. This is the absolute smithy of British greatness because the Royal Navy is incomparable. It's the future. It's a preview of the future.
类事情。是的，我总是记得当我阅读皇家海军伟大历史学家内马尔·罗杰的作品时记住的一句话，当时我们正在做关于特拉法加海战的那期节目。他说，在许多方面，海军机构代表了18世纪乡村中的一个个19世纪的岛屿，像查塔姆或朴茨茅斯这样地方，是世界上任何地方技术和工业化的最前沿。这是英国伟大的绝对锻造炉，因为皇家海军是无与伦比的。它是未来。是对未来的预览。
It is the future. So Nelson goes down there and he gets on the ship, the Raisin Arble. And Dominic, the Raisin Arble, I mean, that's French. So presumably this is a captured French ship. It must be a captured ship. And you'll often see that, that their ships have the wrong names. Yeah. Because they've been captured. Of course, each ship, just to stress this, each ship is an exceedingly
它就是未来。所以纳尔逊去了那里，他登上了“理智号”。多米尼克，“理智号”这个名字，我的意思是，那是法语。所以这大概是一艘被俘获的法国船。它一定是一艘被俘获的船。你经常会看到这种情况，他们的船名字都不对。是的。因为它们是被俘获的。当然，每一艘船，为了强调这一点，每一艘船都是一件极其
expensive and modern piece of kit of hardware. So one thing that's important to remember from the very beginning is the one thing most people don't want to do is to lose their ship because they're so expensive. So to capture an enemy's ship is the ultimate, and it's quite rare. It doesn't happen as often as you would think because often sea battles are a bit inconclusive, aren't they? And as we'll see in Nelson's career, one of the extraordinary things about him is that his sea battles are never inconclusive. Well, yes. And I think that this is a running theme that we'll explore over the series that for most of the 18th century, the concept of a sea battle is that you line up and you
昂贵且现代的硬件装备。所以从一开始需要记住的一件重要事情是，大多数人最不想做的事情就是失去他们的船，因为它们太贵了。因此，俘获敌人的船是终极目标，而且这相当罕见。它不像你想象的那样经常发生，因为海战往往有点难分胜负，不是吗？正如我们将在纳尔逊的职业生涯中所看到的，关于他的一件非凡的事情是，他的海战从不模棱两可。嗯，是的。我认为这将贯穿我们整个系列探讨的一个主题是，在18世纪的大部分时间里，海战的概念是排成一列，然后
fire at each other across a distance, precisely because you don't want to risk losing a ship. But the technological advances that are being honed in the dockyards and the expertise that British gunners are able to display relative to their adversaries means that people like Nelson over the course of the 1790s are starting to think actually we can practice, aim for a battle of utter annihilation in which we will capture ships and this is a key, key theme and Nelson basically becomes the cutting edge of that concept. He does indeed, but for the time being he's obviously just a midshipman. He's 12 years old. You can imagine him on the ship, probably terrified.
隔着一段距离向对方开火，正是因为你不想冒失去船只的风险。但在造船厂中磨练出的技术进步，以及英国炮手相对于对手所展现出的专业技能，意味着像纳尔逊这样的人在1790年代开始思考：实际上我们可以付诸实践，去争取一场彻底歼灭的战斗，在这场战斗中我们将俘获敌人的船只。这是一个关键、关键的主题，而纳尔逊基本上成为了这一概念的最前沿。他的确如此，但目前他显然只是一名见习军官。他才12岁。你可以想象他在船上，可能吓坏了。
Hey, show Nelson reporting for duty, sir. Exactly. Nervous but excited. And actually, when I was writing this in the Adventures in Time book, I thought to myself, this is so much the trajectory of so many great children's stories. Tom Brown's school days. Yeah. The little boy who has to literally learn the ropes. Yeah, of course. We know the names of the other boys.
“见习军官纳尔逊前来报到，长官。”正是如此。紧张但兴奋。其实，当我把这些写进《时间历险记》这本书时，我心里想：这太符合那么多伟大儿童故事的发展轨迹了。《汤姆·布朗的求学时代》。是的。那个必须字面意义上“学会应对”（learn the ropes）的小男孩。是的，当然。我们知道其他男孩的名字。
There's one in particular called Charlie Boyles, who was also from Norfolk, who seems to have taken him under his wing. Thanks to the captain, they would have learned astronomy, navigation, gunnery. They'd have learned to climb the ropes. They'd have learned swordsmanship, pistol shooting, but captains usually instructed their midshipmen in other things as well, the more civilized arts. So they might learn to dance or they might learn to speak French. But not in Nelson's case. No, they would one day go ashore to represent Britain in Naples
有一个叫查理·博伊尔斯的男孩特别引人注目，他也是诺福克人，似乎对纳尔逊格外关照。在船长的指导下，他们会学习天文学、航海术、火炮术。他们会学习爬绳索。他们会学习剑术、手枪射击，但船长通常也会教导见习军官其他事情，比如更文明的艺术。所以他们可能会学习跳舞，或者学习说法语。但在纳尔逊的例子中并非如此。不，他们有一天要上岸去代表英国，在那不勒斯
or in Menorca or wherever it might be. And they would be expected to be gentlemen. So it's not just how to run the ship, it's how to be a gentleman. And actually going back to your point about the modernity, when he's off on the raisonable, he is now part of the most modern institution of its kind anywhere in the world. So the best financed, the best organized, the biggest bureaucracy. I mean the headquarters at the Admiralty is the world's most modern office building. And the reason for this of course we should just spend a moment to explain why the navy matters so much. Britain is much smaller than france but it cannot possibly compete with france's land army the way it succeeds is by trade.
或梅诺卡岛或任何可能的地方。并且他们将被期望成为绅士。所以这不仅是如何管理船只，更是如何成为一名绅士。事实上，回到你关于现代性的观点上，当他在“理智号”上时，他现在是同类中最现代机构的一部分，遍及世界任何地方。因此它是资金最充足、组织最好、官僚机构最大的机构。我的意思是，海军部的总部是世界上最现代化的办公大楼。当然，其中的原因我们应该花点时间解释一下为什么海军如此重要。英国比法国小得多，它根本不可能在陆军上与法国竞争，它成功的方式是通过贸易。
is by trade and by the Royal Navy protecting the sea lanes that keep that trade going. So I had a passage in my book, which I admit has a slight degree of invention, where Uncle Morris, Captain Suckling reads Nelson a passage from A Naval History of England, which was genuinely published in 1735 by Thomas Ledyard. Our trade is the mother and nurse of our seamen, our seaman the life of our fleet, and our fleet the security and protection of our trade, and both together are the wealth, strength and glory of Great Britain. And I think Nelson absolutely, you know, he goes off to the Caribbean, he goes off to India, he is the embodiment of that ethos of trade and naval power interlinked.
是通过贸易以及皇家海军保护维持该贸易继续的海上航线。因此，我的书里有一段话，我承认有一定程度的虚构，莫里斯叔叔（萨克灵船长）给纳尔逊朗读了《英格兰海军史》中的一段话，该书确实于1735年由托马斯·莱迪亚德出版。“我们的贸易是我们的海员的母亲和保姆，我们的海员是我们的舰队的生命，我们的舰队是我们的贸易的安全和保障，两者结合在一起就是大列颠的财富、力量和荣耀。”我想纳尔逊绝对（你知道的）他去了加勒比海，去了印度，他就是贸易与海军力量交织在一起的那种精神的化身。
I mean, I think that to serve on a Royal Navy ship it's like a constant process of education. So it's very moving that Nelson keeps a weather log from when he starts as a midshipman right the way up to his death and he's recording everything that he sees in terms of the weather and this behavior of the seas and everything because this is what will enable him to understand what he's doing. But on top of that, as you said, he's learning science. So it's like going to MIT or something. He's learning how the economy functions. So it's like going to business school.
我的意思是，在皇家海军的舰艇上服役就像是一个持续不断的教育过程。所以非常感人的是，纳尔逊从他开始担任见习军官一直到去世，都坚持记录气象日志，他记录了他在天气和海洋行为以及所有方面看到的一切，因为这将使他能够理解他在做什么。不仅如此，正如你所说，他在学习科学。所以这就像去麻省理工学院或类似的地方。他在学习经济是如何运作的。所以这就像去商学院。
Obviously you're learning the art of gunnery and all that kind of stuff, but you are also seeing the world you're on a constant horizon, expanding process of education. So if you are the kind of boy who is curious, you know, this is an amazing, amazing opportunity and Nelson is exactly the kind of boy who is out there to take full advantage of it. Absolutely. And he must have been good from the beginning because by the time he's 14, his uncle has got him well, first of all, his uncle gets him a birth for a time going
显然你在学习火炮艺术和所有这类东西，但你也在看着这个世界——你正处于一个不断开阔眼界的教育过程中。所以如果你是一个充满好奇心的男孩，你知道的，这是一个惊人、惊人的机会，而纳尔逊正是那种充分利用这一机会的男孩。绝对是的。而且他从一开始一定就很优秀，因为到他14岁时，他的叔叔已经为他——首先，他的叔叔为他安排了一次去
off to the Caribbean. We don't know much about that. It seems that as a midshipman, he would almost certainly have spent all his time pretty much on the ship, kind of fetching and carrying, learning the ropes and all that stuff. Then he commands a longboat that goes up and down the Thames, sort of transporting men and messages, kind of visitors to the ship, people going back to London or that kind of thing. Again, that's quite a responsibility for a 14-year-old. men and messages, kind of visitors to the ship, people going back to London or that kind of thing. Again, that's quite a responsibility for a 14 year old.
加勒比海的航行。我们对那次航行知之甚少。看起来作为一名见习军官，他几乎肯定把所有时间都花在了船上，做些跑腿、学规矩之类的杂务。然后他指挥了一艘在泰晤士河上上下下的小艇，运送人员和信件，运送登船的访客，回伦敦的人或类似的人。再说一次，这对一个14岁的孩子来说责任可真不小。运送人员和信件，运送登船的访客，回伦敦的人或类似的人。再说一次，这对一个14岁的孩子来说责任可真不小。
And then his first really great adventure. I mean, this is the strange thing about his life. Most of us would love to have one of these adventures. Nelson has so many that they all kind of, you know, he must have forgotten half of them. But this is a tremendous one. So May 1773, one of his uncle's friends is putting together a crew to go to the Arctic because they've been told to go and find the Northeast Passage, which is basically, if you look at a map, there's this great frozen island, Spitsbergen, inside the Arctic Circle, and they're hoping they
然后是他真正意义上的第一次伟大冒险。我的意思是，他的人生真是不可思议。我们大多数人都希望能有这样一次冒险。而纳尔逊经历过太多次，以至于它们都融为一体，你知道的，他肯定已经忘了一半了。但这真是一次了不起的经历。那是1773年5月，他叔叔的一个朋友正在组建一个船员队伍前往北极，因为他们接到命令去寻找西北通道。基本上，如果你看地图，北极圈内有一个巨大的冰冻岛屿——斯匹次卑尔根群岛，他们希望
can find a channel to the east of Spitsbergen that will take them around the top of Russia. If you're all the way around the top of Russia. If you're all the way around the top of Russia, you'll eventually get to Japan. Get to Japan, yeah. And then China. And one of the captains of this expedition, a man with a splendid name of Skeffington Lutwidge. Yeah, which is clearly made up. Oh, it's very Harry Potter. He owes Uncle Maurice a favour and he says, I'll take Nelson, even though the Admiralty has actually said, please just take people who experience this is no place for them. So Nelson is absolutely the youngest person on this expedition. By miles.
能在斯匹次卑尔根群岛以东找到一条通道，带领他们绕过俄罗斯的北部。如果你一直绕过俄罗斯的北部。如果你一直绕过俄罗斯的北部，你最终会到达日本。到达日本，是的。然后是中国。这次探险的其中一位船长，是一个有着十分响亮名字的人——斯凯芬顿·勒特维奇。是的，这名字显然是虚构的。哦，非常哈利·波特风格。他欠莫里斯叔叔一个人情，他说：我带上纳尔逊，尽管海军部其实已经说过，请只带那些有经验的人，这里不适合他们。所以纳尔逊绝对是这次探险中最年轻的人。远远甩开其他人。
Yeah. So they set off to the Arctic. And again, this is a brilliant example of the Navy's modernity. They have pioneering sort of Arctic suits called Fiannaut suits. I love that. Why isn't someone manufacturing them now? Fiannaut is a brilliant marketing word. It is.
是的。于是他们出发前往北极。同样，这也是海军现代性的一大绝佳例证。他们拥有名为“Fiannaut”的开创性北极服装。我太喜欢这个了。为什么现在没有人生产它们呢？“Fiannaut”是一个绝妙的市场营销词汇。确实如此。
They have huge quantities of tea and of sugar and wine and soup. They have chronometers, sea clocks that will allow them to work out the time. The great invention. Exactly. And off they go. And he must have, for the first time, have seen seals and whales and things like that, which must be very exciting. The Royal Navy are not very good on preserving Marine fauna, are they?
他们有大量的茶、糖、葡萄酒和汤。他们有天文钟，也就是能让他们计算时间的航海钟。伟大的发明。正是如此。他们就这样出发了。他一定生平第一次见到了海豹、鲸鱼之类动物，这一定非常令人兴奋。英国皇家海军在保护海洋动物方面可不怎么在行，对吧？
So they only have to see a walrus and they're kind of shooting it. Yeah, exactly. And they get to Spitsbergen and whalers say to them, passing whalers say, there's very thick ice nearby, you know, watch out. But they keep going anyway, cause you know, they're British. Ah, whatever, let's plough on. And basically by the end of July, they've got very deep in the ice pack. It's incredibly foggy and these two ships and they keep going very slowly.
所以他们只要看到一头海象就会顺便开枪射击它。是的，完全如此。他们到达了斯匹次卑尔根群岛，捕鲸者对他们说，路过的捕鲸者说：附近有非常厚的冰，你知道的，小心点。但他们还是继续前进，因为你知道的，他们是英国人嘛。啊，管他呢，我们冲过去吧。基本上到7月底，他们已经深入到冰层之中了。大雾弥漫，这两艘船继续非常缓慢地前进。
It's very like the terror. But if you've seen that TV drama. Franklin expedition, isn't it? Yeah. And then eventually they just grind to a halt and they're completely trapped in this ice. And they hear the cracking of ice all around them. Now there's a story at this point, Tom, that I know you love, but which is completely trapped in this ice. And they hear the cracking of ice all around them.
这非常像美剧《极地恶灵》（The Terror）。如果你看过那部电视剧的话。富兰克林探险队，对吧？是的。然后最终他们停滞不前，完全被困在了冰里。他们听到周围到处都是冰层开裂的声音。此时此刻有一个故事，汤姆，我知道你很喜欢它，但它完全被困在了冰里。他们听到周围到处都是冰层开裂的声音。
Now there's a story at this point, Tom, that I know you love, but which is undoubtedly untrue. Would you like to tell it anyway? So the story goes, and this is reported throughout the 19th century in escalatingly dramatic terms, that Nelson ends up confronting a polar bear and he pursues it and kills it. And I'll quote from one of the Victorian accounts, on his return, Captain Luckwich reprimanded him for leaving the ship without leave and in a severe tone demanded what motive could possibly induce him to undertake so rash an action. The young hero with great simplicity replied, I wished sir to get the skin for my father.
现在，在这个时候有一个故事，汤姆，我知道你很热爱它，但毫无疑问是假的。你无论如何都想讲讲吗？故事是这样的，整个19世纪都有关于它的报道，且用词越来越戏剧化：纳尔逊最终面对了一只北极熊，他追赶并杀死了它。我引用一位维多利亚时代作家的记述：“在他归来时，勒特维奇船长因他擅离职守而训斥了他，并以严厉的语气询问究竟是什么动机促使他进行如此轻率的行动。这位年轻的英雄以极其单纯的语气回答道：‘我希望，长官，能为我父亲剥一张熊皮。’”
But we know that Edmund Nelson was the kind of man who would have no business with a polar bear's skin. And as you say, we know that this didn't actually happen because we have the log. The log simply says a bear came close to the ship on the ice, but on the people's going towards him, he went away, which is a good deal less dramatic. But you will always see in books about Nelson, the polar bear, kind of dramatic images of the young hero. I actually had to really restrain myself when I did this book.
但我们知道，埃德蒙·纳尔逊是那种根本不会去管北极熊皮的人。正如你所说，我们知道这其实并没有发生，因为我们有航海日志。航海日志只是简单地记录道：“一只熊在冰上靠近了船，但在人们向它走去时，它走开了。”这要少得多戏剧性。但你在关于纳尔逊的书籍中总是能看到北极熊，看到这位年轻英雄的戏剧性画卷。当我写这本书时，我真的不得不极力克制自己。
I'm heroic forbearance. From not having, you know, the bear strikes at chapter seven or something. But anyway, he doesn't fight the bear in the book. So basically what they were going to have to do was unload the ship and drag everything on these launches towards where they hoped they would find the sea and then wave and basically hail away. I mean, a terrible scene. They could, I mean, probably they would have died, I would say, unless they were very lucky. But he is fortunate. Dame Fortune smiles on him, I think it's fair to say throughout his career, because they've been dragging these launches for two days or one and a half days, I think it is, to say throughout his career because they've been dragging these launches
充满英雄般的克制。不要在第七章之类的地方写“熊发动袭击”之类的桥段。总之，他在书中并没有与熊搏斗。基本上，他们不得不做的是卸下船上的货物，把所有的东西都拖到这些舰载小艇上，朝着他们希望找到海洋的地方前进，然后挥手呼喊，基本上就是撤离。我的意思是，那是一个可怕的场景。他们可能会，我的意思是，如果不是运气极好的话，他们大概会死在那里。但他很幸运。幸运女神对微笑着，我认为可以公平地说，贯穿了他的整个职业生涯，因为他们已经拖着这些小艇走了两天或者一天半，我想是这样的，
for two days or one and a half days, I think it is, and going back to the ship to sleep. And then one day they get up to do it again, have another go, and they hear this great cracking sound. The ice is breaking up and what is better, the current is carrying their ship towards the sea. Southwards. So tremendous scenes. They end up making it back home. They haven't found the North East Passage. But again, for a teenager, what is he 14, 15? 15. Yeah. It is an unbelievable experience. And he gets a silver watch out of it doesn't he? Yes, he's given by the
并且回到船上去睡觉。然后有一天他们醒来准备再干一次，再试一次，这时他们听到了巨大的破裂声。冰块正在碎裂，更好的是，洋流正把他们的船推向大海。向南。所以那是极其壮观的景象。他们最终回到了家。他们没有找到西北通道。但对于一个十几岁的少年来说，他当时多大？14岁还是15岁？15岁。是的。这是一次难以置信的经历。而且他从中得到了一块银怀表，不是吗？是的，探险队的指挥官们送给他一块银怀表，他将其视为一生的珍宝。上面刻着这次北极探险的细节。
commanders of the expedition a silver watch that he treasures for the rest of his life. It's engraved with the details of this kind of Arctic expedition. So this is an amazing training. So today while lads will be doing GCSEs, he's off braving the North East Passage. Exactly. And then as if that's not enough, when he gets back, Captain Suckling says, oh, I found you another little trip. Little birth. One of my friends is looking for a midshipman on his ship, the seahorse, to go to India.
所以这是一次惊人的训练。因此，如今当小伙子们还在应付普通中等教育证书考试（GCSE）时，他已经在勇敢地闯过西北通道了。正是如此。就好像这还不够似的，等他回来后，萨克灵船长说：哦，我又给你找到了一个小差事。一个小岗位。我的一个朋友正在他的船“海马号”（Seahorse）上寻找一名见习军官去印度。
And there their job is to the Royal Navy is basically providing protection. It's escorting East India Company trading ships from local pirates and raiders and so on and so forth. And this is Nelson's introduction to the fact that being in the Royal Navy obliges you to have a sense of geopolitics. Yes, absolutely. Because he's kind of dealing with the local bigwigs along the Indian coast and so on. Exactly.
在那里，皇家海军的工作基本上是提供保护。它护送东印度公司的商船免受当地海盗和袭击者等的侵害。这是纳尔逊首次意识到，身处皇家海军意味着你必须具备地缘政治意识。是的，绝对如此。因为他当时要和印度海岸一带的当地权贵等人打交道。正是如此。
So he goes on this massive journey now. He's been to the Arctic and now he goes off on this journey. They go down, round Africa, you know, obviously the heat rising, great sense of excitement as they near India. When he's on this very long voyage, he meets two people who are very important for him. One is a young able seaman called Thomas Truebridge. The fact that he's an able seaman tells you that he's from a humbler background. So he hasn't gone through that midshipman kind of initiation. Exactly. He's not on, as it were, the fast track, but Troubridge, as we will see, becomes a very
于是他开启了一段漫长的征程。他去过北极，现在又踏上了这段旅程。他们向南绕过非洲，你知道的，气温明显升高，随着逐渐接近印度，内心充满了兴奋。在这次非常漫长的航行中，他遇到了对他的生平至关重要两个人。其中一个是年轻的水兵，名叫托马斯·特鲁布里ッジ。他是水兵这一事实表明他出身卑微。所以他并没有经历过那种见习军官式的入门培训。一点没错。他可以说是没有走上捷径，但正如我们将要看到的，特鲁布里ッジ成为了纳尔逊非常
close friend and comrade of Nelson. And then sadly, a bit of a rival at the end of their lives. Their relations sour a little bit, but he's really important for Nelson and his name will come up again and again. And then the other person is the ship's master, who's an Irishman called Thomas Surridge. And he can spot that Nelson is very talented, and Surridge spends a lot of time with him, teaching him navigation. He gets Nelson... Lots of maths, isn't there? Yeah, to take the measurements on the ship. He says, you do it. And Surridge is the first in a series of patrons, father figures, I suppose. The Edmund Nelson, his own father, is not a very good father figure to him because they're
亲密的朋友和战友。遗憾的是，到了他们生命的晚年，他成了纳尔逊的一个竞争对手。他们的关系稍微有点变坏了，但对纳尔逊来说他真的很重要，而且他的名字将一次又一次地出现。另一个人则是船长，一个名叫托马斯·萨里奇的爱尔兰人。他看出纳尔逊极具天赋，萨里奇花了很多时间教他航海术。他让纳尔逊……有很多数学内容，对吧？是的，去测量船上的数据。他说，你来做。萨里奇可以说是纳尔逊众多恩人和父亲形象中的第一个。埃德蒙·纳尔逊，他自己的父亲并不是一个很好的父亲形象，因为他们俩
so different. And also he's so far away and he's sat there in front of his fire reading about the Bible. Exactly. That's not going to help you kill the French. No, no, no, no, no. Or indeed fight off a polar bear, if only apocryphally. So he spends the summer of 1775 escorting company ships to and fro across the Indian Ocean. He goes to Basra, he goes to Bombay, he goes to Ceylon, now Sri Lanka.
实在太不一样了。而且他离得那么远，就坐在火炉前读《圣经》。确实如此。这可帮不了你杀法国人。不，不，不，不，不。或者甚至击退一只北极熊，虽然这只是传说。因此，他度过了1775年的夏天，在印度洋上护送公司的船只来回穿梭。他去过巴士拉，去过孟买，去过锡兰（现为斯里兰卡）。
But this is not a healthy place for Royal Navy sailors, so sickness is very common. In early 1776, Nelson falls ill with what I think most biographers believe is malaria. It's malaria, isn't it? Yeah. He is seriously ill and arguably he never really recovers. I mean, this is the thing with malaria in the late 18th century. If you get it, it will quite probably plague you for the rest of your life. So he is sent back home to save his life and off they go.
但对皇家海军水兵来说，这里并不是一个健康的地方，因此疾病非常普遍。1776年初，纳尔逊患上了一种病，大多数传记作家认为那是疟疾。那是疟疾，对吧？是的。他病得很重，可以说他再也没有真正康复过。我是说，18世纪末期的疟疾就是这样。一旦染上，它很可能会折磨你余下的整个生命。因此，为了挽救他的生命，他被送回了家，于是他们启程了。
And he's feeling quite despondent, isn't it? He's very despondent. You know, he's very ill and he must be worrying that his career is over almost before it's begun. Well, Nelson is not, I think it's fair to say, just to talk about his psychology. We said he was, you know, slender and he's sickly and whatnot. He's also given to very extravagant mood swings, isn't he? When he's depressed, he's properly depressed.
他当时感觉挺沮丧的，对吧？他非常沮丧。你知道的，他病得很重，一定在担心他的职业生涯还没真正开始就要结束了。嗯，我认为客观地说，纳尔逊不仅仅是心理上有问题，我们说过他，你知道的，身材苗条，身体孱弱等等。他的情绪也总是极不稳定，对吧？当他消沉时，他是真的消沉。
He's sweating, he's feverish, they're going around Africa and he's incredibly miserable. And as you say, I think he thinks, oh, it's all up. You know, I might die or I'm too sick to stay in the Navy. But then Dominic, his seal for king and country comes to his rescue. Can I read it? Do read it, Tom. That'd be lovely. Okay. Yeah. As you say, he's rounding Africa and he has this kind of this flash of insight and he wrote about it. I could discover no means of reaching the object of my ambition.
他浑身冒汗，发着高烧，他们正在绕过非洲，他痛苦不堪。正如你所说，我想他当时一定在想，哦，全完了。你知道的，我可能会死，或者我病得太重，无法继续留在海军了。但随后，多米尼克，他对国王和国家的忠诚前来拯救了他。我能读一下吗？读吧，汤姆。那太好了。好的。是的。正如你所说，他在绕非洲航行时突然有了某种顿悟，他对此进行了记录。我找不到任何实现我雄心壮志的途径。
After a long and gloomy reverie in which I almost wished myself overboard, a sudden glow of patriotism was kindled within me and presented my king and country as my patron. My mind exalted in the idea. Well then, I exclaimed, I will be a hero and confiding in providence, I will brave every danger. I love Nelson Tom. And you know what? I think he really did think that.
经过一番漫长而阴郁的沉思，我甚至恨不得跳进海里，突然间，一股爱国主义的热情在我心中燃起，将我的国王和国家呈现在我面前，视他们为我的恩人。我的心灵为这个想法而欢欣鼓舞。好吧，我当时大声喊道，我将成为一名英雄，并坚信上天保佑，我将勇敢面对一切危险。我爱纳尔逊，汤姆。你知道吗？我想他当时真的是那样想的。
I don't think he's making that up to you. I think that's exactly the kind of thing he thinks. Well, I know that we have a lot of listeners in their teens, maybe wondering what to do with their lives. And I think that they could all profit from that. They could indeed. Right. Let's take a break. And when we return, let's take the lieutenants exam and let us confront some of the worst people who will meet in this story. The tax dodgers of the American colonists. See you then.
我不认为那是他编出来骗你的。我认为这正是他那种人会有的想法。嗯，我知道我们有很多十几岁的听众，他们可能正在琢磨自己的人生该做些什么。我想他们都能从中受益。他们确实能。好了。我们休息一下。等我们回来，去参加中尉考试，并去面对我们在这个故事中将遇到的最糟糕的一些人。美国殖民地的逃税者。回头见。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are following the career of England's greatest hero, Horatio Nelson and Dominic. We left him feeling sorry for himself and then getting a patriotic glow and so he's come back from India full of patriotism. What's going on? So the big thing for him as for any midshipman is to get up the next stage to pass the Lieutenant's exam. He does that in April 1777. I love this. He has to go to the, to a board, yeah, to the naval office in the city. There are three officers. Yeah. And one of these officers, who's that? By an extraordinary stroke of fortune, it's his uncle Morris. Right. There's a turn up for the books. Now,
大家好，欢迎回到《历史就是这样》。我们将继续关注英格兰最伟大的英雄霍雷肖·纳尔逊的生平，多米尼克。我们离开他时，他还在顾影自怜，随后便燃起了爱国热情，于是他满怀爱国主义从印度回来了。接下来发生了什么？所以对他来说，就像对任何见习军官一样，头等大事就是迈向下一阶段，通过中尉考试。他在1777年4月做到了这一点。我太喜欢这个了。他必须去，去参加一个委员会的面试，是的，去城里的海军办公室。那里有三位军官。是的。这些军官中有一位是谁呢？通过极其神奇的运气，他是他的叔叔莫里斯。好吧。这可真是个意想不到的转折。现在，
uncle Morris said later that he only said to the other examiners at the end, after they had all agreed to pass Horatio. Of course he did. Only at the end did he say, well, dad, we've decided to pass him because as it happens, he's my nephew. Clearly this isn't the case. And it's that point, isn't it? The Navy is one of the most meritocratic institutions in the world at that point, but it is also by our standards, you know, riddled with nepotism and patronage. Well, you need patrons and that's accepted. And Nelson understands this as someone who is dependent on patronage that they will help him and in due course when he's in a position to offer patronage, he will do so and go to great efforts to do it.
莫里斯叔叔后来声称，他是在最后，在所有考官都同意让霍雷肖通过之后，才对其他人说了那句话。他当然会这么说。直到最后他才说，好吧，伙计们，我们决定让他通过，因为碰巧的是，他是我侄子。显然事实并非如此。也就是在这个时候，对吧？海军在当时是世界上最具任人唯贤性质的机构之一，但按照我们的标准，它也充斥着裙带关系和恩庇侍从主义。嗯，你需要恩人，这是被普遍接受的。作为一个依赖恩庇的人，纳尔逊明白这一点，他们会帮助他，并且当他日后有能力提供恩庇时，他也会这样做，并为此付出巨大努力。
That's the system. And feel that it's not corrupt, that it's his duty. No. And nobody at the time, if you'd said to them this is corruption, they would have frowned. They would have said, no, that's the system. We just want that put on the record. Nelson does nothing wrong here. And also he's going to pass anyway because he's brilliant.
这就是那套体制。并且觉得这并非腐败，而是他的职责。没错。当时如果有人对他们说这是腐败，他们会皱起眉头。他们会说，不，这就是体制。我们只是想把这一点记录在案。纳尔逊在这里没有做错任何事。而且无论如何他都能通过，因为他太优秀了。
He has been to the Caribbean, he's been to the Arctic, he's been to India. He literally does know the ropes. And he's about 10. He has sailed for almost 50,000 miles. So clearly he's going to pass. I mean he's up there with Captain Cook's goat. So now he's on this ladder that hopefully if he plays his cards right, you know, the dream is you're on this ladder.
他去过加勒比海，去过北极，去过印度。他对这里的门道确实了如指掌。而且他大概10岁（注：此处原文为口误或夸张）。他已经航行了将近5万英里。所以很显然他肯定能通过。我的意思是，他和库克船长的山羊不相上下。所以现在他踏上了这条阶梯，如果他运气好的话，你知道的，梦想就是能登上这条阶梯。
There are a lot of people competing, but what you want is to see your name on that captain's list, you know, the bottom of the captain's list. You've got onto the list. You become Lieutenant, don't you? Then you become Master and Commander and then you become captain. Exactly. And your name will be posted in the London Gazette and you might, if you're lucky, get a ship of your own because there are actually more ships than there are captains,
有很多人在竞争，但你想要的是看到你的名字出现在那份船长名单上，你知道的，就是船长名单的末尾。你已经上了这份名单。你成了中尉，对吧？然后你成了指挥官，接着你成了船长。正是如此。你的名字将会被刊登在《伦敦宪报》上，如果你幸运的话，你可能会拥有一艘自己的船，因为实际上船的数量比船长的数量还要多，
which is a slight issue. You mentioned Master and Commander. Those books, the Patrick O'Brien books, and particularly the first one, Master and Commander, is brilliant on this sort of sense of gnawing anxiety. You really need to get on the captain's list because only then can you start to make any serious money out of this. Yeah, people who've listened to this podcast from the beginning will know that initially I was very opposed to Patrick O'Brien because there was an excessive rope and I have now seen the light. You have indeed, yeah.
这算是一个小问题。你提到了指挥官。那些书，帕トリック·奥布赖恩的书，尤其是第一本《怒海争锋》（Master and Commander），非常绝妙地展现了那种折磨人的焦虑感。你真的必须要登上船长名单，因为只有到了那个时候，你才能开始从中赚取任何可观的钱。是的，从一开始就收听这个播客的人会知道，最初我是非常反对帕トリック·奥布赖恩的，因为里面有太多关于索具的描写，而现在我终于看清了真相。你确实看清了，是的。
And I recognise that they are just as good as everyone says. It was a very lovely moment when you admitted how wrong you'd been. I can sometimes admit I'm wrong. So what he really needs to get on is a war. And I said in the first half that often fortune is with him. And once again, fortune is with him because at precise this point, remember it's April 1777, there is a dispute about paying rightful taxes, which some listeners may be familiar with in the American colonies.
我承认它们和每个人说的一样好。当你承认自己之前有多么错误时，那真是一个非常美妙的时刻。我有时确实能承认自己错了。所以他真正需要的是一场战争。我在前半部分说过，命运往往站在他这一边。而这一次，命运再次站在了他这一边，因为正是在这个时候，记住那是1777年4月，发生了一场关于支付合法税款的争端，美国殖民地的某些听众可能对此并不陌生。
Talks with the rebels have broken down. American privateers have started attacking British merchant ships. There is already talk of them potentially threatening the most lucrative part of Britain's empire, the Sugar Islands of Jamaica and Barbados. And so Nelson immediately gets a posting, a second in command, on a frigate called the Lowest Off which is bound for Jamaica. So the American Revolution, not all bad.
与叛军的谈判已经破裂。美国私掠船开始攻击英国商船。甚至已经有人在讨论他们可能会威胁到英国帝国最利润丰厚的部分——牙买加和巴巴多斯的产糖群岛。于是纳尔逊立刻得到了一份职务，在一艘名为“最低岸”号（Lowestoff）的巡洋舰上担任大副，该舰正开往牙买加。所以说，美国独立战争并非全无坏处。
Not all bad, no. Because it gives Nelson his opportunity. Because it did give one of history's greatest characters the chance to advance, which is lovely. Yeah, well that's good to bear in mind. That's nice for American listeners to have some kind words from us for once. So when he's on the Lowest Off, he meets another of these really, really important patron figures, a captain called William Locker. Locker is extremely experienced. He has fought against the French many times. He fought against them 20 years earlier.
并非全无坏处，是的。因为它给了纳尔逊机会。因为它确实给了历史上最伟大的人物之一一个崭露头角的机会，这真是太好了。是的，把这一点记在心里挺好的。这对美国听众来说也是个好消息，难得能从我们这里听到一些好话。所以在“最低岸”号上，他遇到了另一位非常非常重要的恩人，一位名叫威廉·洛克的船长。洛克经验极其丰富。他与法国人作战过多次。他20岁时就与他们交过手。
He's got a French bullet in his leg, hasn't he? He did. He got a French bullet in his leg because he had stormed a French privateer. And Locker is massive for Nelson because Locker teaches him, I think, two things. Number one is how to be a leader. Locker is quite a kindly captain. He's paternalistic. He believes it's better to be loved than to be feared. Of course, there's always an element of fear. I mean, you have to have respect. So, you know, the occasional flogging, everyone expects that. Yeah. Everybody thinks, I mean, we do that and the rest is history with their producers. Yeah. Yeah.
他的腿里有一颗法国子弹，对吧？是的，确实如此。他腿里有一颗法国子弹，因为他曾率领部下突袭了一艘法国私掠船。洛克对纳尔逊的影响巨大，因为我认为洛克教给了他两件事。第一件事是如何成为一名领导者。洛克是一位相当亲切的船长。他带有家长式作风。他认为受人爱戴好过令人畏惧。当然，恐惧的成分总是存在的。我的意思是，你必须赢得尊重。所以，你知道的，偶尔鞭笞一下，大家都是预料之中的。是的。每个人都认为——我的意思是，我们和我们的制作人也是这么做的。是的。是的。
So there's that element to Locker. And then the other one is that Locker says to him, you know how to beat the French. You go straight at them. Going close. Because we will always have better firepower, better discipline, and none of this faffing around from a distance. Yeah, blasting at each other. So this is so interesting because this is people working this out. So it's even in the 1780s, this sense that actually we're good enough on the Royal
所以洛克身上有那种特质。另一件事是，洛克对他说，你知道如何击败法国人。你要直接冲向他们。贴近他们。因为我们总是拥有更强大的火力、更好的纪律，绝不搞那些保持距离的虚晃一枪。是的，互相轰炸。所以这非常有趣，因为这是人们在摸索规律。所以在18世纪80年代，人们就已经有这种意识了：实际上我们在皇家海军中足够优秀，
Navy that we can go in close, we can go in hard. Exactly. We can change our tactics. We can adopt something else. Nelson picks up on this. Yes. Lay a Frenchman close and you will beat him, Locker says. And actually, big preview. We will end this series at the Battle of the Nile. And after the Battle of the Nile, Nelson wrote to Locker. So this is years later when Nelson is an international celebrity. And Nelson said to Locker, pretty much everything I have is down to you. My old friend, nothing can alter my attachment and gratitude to you. My only merit in my profession is being your scholar and our friendship
我们可以靠得很近，我们可以猛烈进攻。正是如此。我们可以改变战术。我们可以采用别的方法。纳尔逊领会了这一点。是的，紧贴着一个法国人，你就能战胜他，洛克说。事实上，剧透一下。我们将以尼罗河战役作为本系列的结语。尼罗河战役之后，纳尔逊写信给洛克。这是多年后，纳尔逊已经成为国际名人时的事了。纳尔逊对洛克说，我所拥有的一切几乎都归功于您。我的老朋友，没有什么能改变我对您的依恋和感激。我在职业生涯中唯一的功绩就是做了您的学生，我们的友谊
will never end but with my life." Yeah, very moving. And again, reflection of the way in which the bonds of patronage and teaching kind of serve to join the generations in the Navy. It's really, really important. They do. But also a little insight there, I think, into a part of Nelson's character. He's very sentimental, isn't he, Nelson? Very. So if anybody listens to this and thinks, oh, this would be a good Hollywood melodrama or big series. I think Nelson, he thinks like that.
至死方休。”是的，非常感人。这也再次反映了海军中恩庇与教导纽带将一代代人紧密联系在一起的方式。这真的非常、非常重要。确实如此。但我想这也让我们得以一窥纳尔逊性格中的一部分。他非常多愁善感，对吧，纳尔逊？非常。所以如果任何人听了这些觉得，哦，这会是一部很好的好莱坞情节剧或大型电视剧。我想纳尔逊，他就是那样思考的。
He thinks he's the character in a tremendous story and he behaves accordingly. All his emotions are in bold colors, not pale pastels. Yeah. And it's a British version of the displays of sensibility that we've been talking about in the French Revolution series. That you wear your emotions on your sleeve. And Nelson absolutely does that. Yeah. Even when his sleeve is just dangling there because his arm has been lost. But we'll come to that. All right. So the lowest off arrives in the Caribbean. Now sailors hate going to the Caribbean. They hate it because what they kind of do and they kind of, I mean, captains quite like it, don't they? Because they say you're either going to die or you're going to win glory.
他觉得自己是一部伟大故事中的角色，并且他也会相应地行事。他的所有情感都是鲜艳的色彩，而不是苍白的粉彩。是的。这是我们在法国大革命系列中一直在谈论的那种情感宣泄的英国版本。就是把你的情感都写在脸上。纳尔逊绝对做到了这一点。是的。哪怕他的袖子空荡荡地垂着，因为他的手臂已经失去了。但我们待会儿会讲到这个。好吧。“最低岸”号抵达了加勒比海。现在，水兵们讨厌去加勒比海。他们讨厌那里，因为他们经历的——而且船长们其实挺喜欢的，对吧？因为他们会说，要么你死在那里，要么你赢得荣耀。
Or you can make a lot of money. But for ordinary sailors, the risks here of dysentery or malaria or yellow fever are very great indeed. But of course, what keeps them coming back is the importance of this part of the world to Britain's economy and particularly sugar. And so this, I guess, Tom, is the point at which we should discuss the perhaps slight shadow that has grown over Nelson's reputation in the last, what, five, 10 years in Britain when his name comes up in the newspapers and whatnot. And this is the question of Nelson and slavery. So I think one thing we should say right at the outset is there was one thing that Nelson definitely is not, and that is an abolitionist. He is not an abolitionist by any vague stretch of the imagination, is he? No, it's simply something that he doesn't contemplate. And I think this is the age where abolitionism is starting to pick up steam. So we did an episode on Benjamin Lay, the
要么你能赚大钱。但对于普通水兵来说，在那里染上痢疾、疟疾或黄热病风险确实非常巨大。当然，让他们不断返回那里的原因，是这个地区对英国经济尤其是对糖业的重要性。所以我想，汤姆，这就是我们应该讨论的一点：在过去这五十年里，或者说在英国报纸等媒体提及他的名字时，纳尔逊的声誉上或许已经产生了一丝阴影。这就是纳尔逊与奴隶制的问题。所以我想我们首先应该说的一点是，纳尔逊绝对不是那种人，那就是废奴主义者。无论如何拉扯，他绝不是一个废奴主义者，对吧？不，这根本不是他会去考虑的事情。我认为这是一个废奴主义开始积蓄力量的时代。所以我们曾做过一期关于本杰明·莱的节目，
Quaker abolitionist, and he's really, even among Quakers, he's seen as exceptional. And by the time that Nelson is going to the Caribbean, the Quakers pretty strongly come out against slavery, and you're starting to get evangelicals as well. But Nelson's not a part of this. You know, he spent his childhood in Norfolk, and then he spent it at sea. He would have no time to engage with it. It's plausible. His father is a vicar, but does not seem to have been. But the father doesn't seem to have had any abolitionist sentiment either. So I think it's actually very plausible, if you think that Nelson went to ATC when he
他是贵格会废奴主义者，即使在贵格会内部，他也备受推崇。等到纳尔逊前往加勒比海时，贵格会已经非常强烈地反对奴隶制，并且你也开始看到福音派人士的出现。但纳尔逊并不属于其中。你知道的，他在诺福克度过了童年，然后在海上度过了余生。他根本没有时间去接触这些。这是合乎情理的。他的父亲是一名牧师，但似乎并没有这种倾向。不过他的父亲似乎也没有任何废奴主义情绪。所以我想，如果你认为纳尔逊在
was 12, that he has probably never at that point come up against any abolitionist ideas at all. And as time goes on, he obviously hears of them, but I guess they're not being promoted by people within his service because the Royal Navy is hardly a hotbed of abolitionism at this point. Undoubtedly, he must have seen slavery. There are about 200,000 slaves in Jamaica alone at this point, but it's important to say he's never personally involved in it. So he doesn't own slaves. He never serves on a slave ship. He never trades in slaves.
12岁时就去了海军，那么他在那个时候很可能从未接触过任何废奴主义思想，这其实非常合乎情理。随着时间的推移，他显然听说了这些，但我猜他的军中同僚并没有在宣扬这些，因为当时的皇家海军绝不是废奴主义的温床。毫无疑问，他一定见过奴隶制。当时仅在牙买加就有大约20万奴隶，但必须指出的是，他从未亲自参与其中。所以他不拥有奴隶。他从未在奴隶船上服役。他从未从事过奴隶贸易。
He never invests his money in sugar plantations. So he's not like he's escorting slave ships or anything of that kind. There is a letter though, isn't there, in which he seems to show, while in patience perhaps, would be putting it kindly with William Wilberforce, the evangelical who in Britain is leading campaign against the slave trade. And it's a controversial letter, isn't it?
他从未将钱投资于糖料种植园。所以他并不像是在护送奴隶船或诸如此类的事情。不过，确实有一封信，对吧？在这封信中，他在面对威廉· Wilberforce（威廉·威伯福斯，英国废奴运动领袖）时似乎表现得——如果说他缺乏耐心的话，那可能还算客气——这位在英国领导反对奴隶贸易运动的福音派人士。这是一封有争议的信，对吧？
Yes, he does. I can't remember what he calls it. Something like the damnable doctrine of abolitionism or something like that. Yeah. I'm still not clear whether this is because people have argued that this has been doctored. Others say no, it hasn't. I know that Michael Taylor, who's written brilliantly on abolitionism, says that it is authentic. So I would probably trust his expertise on this. Well, here's the thing. I think what this consensus of Nelson scholars about this letter, that there is definitely a letter written by Nelson and reflects his undoubted skepticism
是的，确实如此。我记不清他是怎么称呼它的了。大概是什么“废奴主义的可诅咒教条”之类的。是的。我依然不清楚这是否是因为——有人争辩说这封信被篡改过。另一些人则说没有，没有被篡改。我知道迈克尔·泰勒，他在废奴主义研究上写过非常出色的著作，他说它是真实的。所以我可能会相信他在这一领域的专业知识。嗯，情况是这样的。我认为纳尔逊学者们对这封信的共识是，纳尔逊确实写过这样一封信，它反映了他对废奴主义无可置疑的怀疑态度。
about abolitionism. However, there's no doubt whatsoever that this letter was doctored after his death. It was kind of to use the the terminology not unfamiliar to other people in the podcasting world, it was like a dossier that had been sexed up, Tom, by pro-slavery advocates after his death because they wanted the interest, the interest exactly, because they wanted to make it look as though Nelson was more fervently in favour of slavery and against abolitionism than perhaps he may have been. And so what he actually wrote is very hard to decipher because what we've got is the kind of doctored version. The one thing we can say is that there is no evidence actually that Nelson was racist. So this is again, you know, the sort of, oh,
然而，毫无疑问的是，这封信在他死后被篡改了。它有点像——用播客界其他人并不陌生的术语来说——它就像是一份被“性感化”的档案，汤姆，是由支持奴隶制的倡导者在他死后炮制的，因为他们想要那种利益，正是为了利益，因为他们想让纳尔逊看起来比他实际可能表现得更加狂热地支持奴隶制并反对废奴主义。所以他到底写了什么很难辨别，因为我们拿到的是被篡改过的版本。我们能确定的唯一一件事是，没有任何证据表明纳尔逊是个种族主义者。所以这也是那种“纳尔逊纪念柱必须倒塌”的学派的观点，即既然他不是废奴主义者，而且鉴于他对废奴主义至少可以说是——为了对他客气一点——非常怀疑，那他也许是个种族主义者。我认为没有任何证据表明他是种族主义者。我们有他数以千计的信件，他在信中从未表露过一丝一毫的偏见。而且正如我们日后将看到的，我的意思是，他将带着黑人社群的支持去战斗。例如舰队中的黑人水兵。他的船上有黑人水兵服役。事实上，其中一人就被雕刻在，
Nelson's column must fall kind of school of thought is well, since he's not an abolitionist, and since he seems to have been at least, shall we say, to be kind to him, very skeptical about abolitionism, maybe he was a racist. I don't think there's any evidence whatsoever that he was racist. We have thousands of his letters and he never says expresses a hint of prejudice in them. And as we'll see in due course, I mean, he's going to be going to war with the support of black communities. Black sailors in the fleet, for example. He has black sailors serve on his ships. In fact, one of them is illustrated, isn't he,
纳尔逊纪念柱的浮雕上？是的，乔治·莱恩，他确实曾在“胜利”号上服役。在特拉法尔加海战的“胜利”号上。但在我们将要讲到的一次远征中，一支英国军队登上了名字听起来有些阴险却又极为贴切的蚊子海岸（Mosquito Coast），他们在那里寻求当地印第安人和当地定居的黑人社群的支持，纳尔逊和他们相处得极为融洽。引用纳尔逊的伟大传记作家约翰·萨格登的话来说，他在谈到那里的印第安人和黑人社群时写道：就霍雷肖而言，他对当地人顽强的生命力以及他们在草丛岛屿之间和湍急激流中驾驭独木舟的技巧印象深刻。而对当地人来说，他们看到的是一个身材和力量都不出众的年轻人，毫无任何欧洲人常见的傲慢，与他们一同艰难前行。所以纳尔逊随时准备赞赏他所见到的勇气。
on the panelling of Nelson's column, The Freezers? Yeah, George Ryan, who served on the victory, actually. On the victory at Trafalgar. But in an expedition that we're coming to a minute where a British force go off to land on the sinisterly named and aptly named Mosquito Coast, and they're looking for support from the local Indians and from black communities that have been settled there, and Nelson gets on brilliantly well with them. So just to quote John Sugden, who's the great biographer of Nelson, he's talking about the Indians and the black communities there. On his part, Horatio was impressed by the durability of the natives and their skill in weaving the boats around grassy islands
哦，绝对是的。我们知道后来纳尔逊家族有一个名叫普莱斯的黑人仆人，他是个获得自由的人，而不是奴隶。纳尔逊在晚年曾对埃玛·汉密尔顿说，我真希望普莱斯能来和我们一起住。他，引述原话，是个绝无仅有的好人。而普莱斯实际上说的是，不，我有比跟埃玛·汉密尔顿闲逛更好的事情要做，我认为这非常合乎情理。这显然不是一个心存种族偏见的人的行为。
and through tumbling rapids. On theirs, the Indians saw a young man of no great strength or size struggling with them in vain without any of the common European arrogance. So Nelson is ready to admire courage where he finds it. Oh, definitely. We know that later on the Nelson family had a black servant called Price, who was a freed man, not a slave. And Nelson actually later in life said to Emma Hamilton, I'd love it if Price could come to live with us. He is, quote, as good a man as ever lived. And Price actually said, no, I've got better things to do than hang around with Emma Hamilton, which I think is very reasonable. That's clearly not the behavior of a man who has a kind of racial prejudice.
但我认为实话实说，纳尔逊其实并不关心这个。我想这绝对是对的。我觉得他只是对这个不感兴趣。他感兴趣的是六分仪、大炮以及诸如此类的事情。他绝对是的。所以现在他身处18世纪70年代末的加勒比海，显然他的重点是战争。而这场战争进行得非常糟糕。驻扎在北美的英国军队离本土有3000英里远。他们的补给线非常糟糕，而且美国人首先得到了武器方面的资助，
But I think the honest truth is that Nelson isn't really interested. I think that's absolutely right. I think he's just not interested in it. He's interested in sextants and canon and all that kind of stuff. Absolutely he is. So now that he's in the Caribbean in the late 1770s, obviously his focus is the war. And the war is going very badly. The British army in North America is 3000 miles from home. They've got very poor supply links, but also the Americans are being funded first of all
还得到了来自法国的资金资助。然后到了1778年，法国直接参战。接着在1779年，西班牙也参战了。像纳尔逊这样的人现在的人的目标基本上就是试图守住我们所能守住的一切，特别是在加勒比海地区。他花了很多时间，并且为自己赢得了巨大的名声，实际上是在为牙买加的防御做准备，以防范法国可能的进攻。而那次进攻从未发生。从某种意义上说，这对纳尔逊来说是个遗憾。因为他没有机会去——
with arms and also with money from France. Then in 1778, the French enter the war directly. And then in 1778, the French enter the war directly. And then in 1779, the Spanish, the goal for people like Nelson now is basically try to hold onto as much as we can, particularly in the Caribbean. And he spends a lot of time and makes a great name for himself actually readying the defenses of Jamaica against a possible French attack. And that never comes. And in a way that's a shame for Nelson. Because he doesn't have a chance to.
是的，即便如此，他做得已经足够出色，以至于加勒比海的英国指挥官彼得·帕克海军上将（Sir Peter Parker）在1779年晋升他为船长，将他列入了那份备受珍视的船长名单中。他在加勒比海期间得到的另一件事是，他再次结识了更多将伴随他整个职业生涯的朋友。他结识的最著名的人物是一个来自泰恩河畔、拥有圆脸的家伙，名叫库思伯特·科林伍德（Cuthbert Collingwood），他其实从1773年起就认识纳尔逊了。所以我的意思是，时间很长了，而且他比纳尔逊大10岁，虽然没有和纳尔逊同时成为船长，但终究会成为船长的。在纳尔逊的整个职业生涯中，似乎科林伍德总是紧随其后。他带着他的狗。
Yeah, but even so he has done well enough for the British commander in the Caribbean, Admiral Sir Peter Parker in 1779 to make him a captain, to put him on that list, the much prized captain's list. And the other thing that he gets from his time in the Caribbean is that he again, he makes more friends who will be with him throughout his career. And the other thing that he gets from his time in the Caribbean is that he, again, he makes more friends who will be with him throughout his career. And the most celebrated of these is a round faced man from the banks of the Tyne called Cuthbert Collingwood, who had actually known Nelson since 1773. So I mean, a long time and was 10 years older, but doesn't become a captain when Nelson becomes
带着他的狗“蹦蹦”。事实上，在特拉法尔加海战中，科林伍德将指挥两个纵队之一。他确实会这样。与纳尔逊并肩作战。所以在此有必要提及他。因此，纳尔逊现在被指派指挥一艘名为“欣钦布鲁克”号（Hinchinbrook）的28门炮巡洋舰。这是他自己的船。对他来说，这是多么美妙的时刻，第一次以船长的身份听着笛声登上了这艘船。但他的生命几乎就在此刻走到了尽头，因为正如你之前所暗示的，汤姆，他参与了一场极其荒唐轻率的远征。我认为公平地说，每当纳尔逊去陆地上的任何地方。如果出了岔子。是的。灾难就不远了。是的。所以牙买加总督有一个疯狂的计划。这支英国部队将登陆蚊子海岸，该海岸位于洪都拉斯和尼加拉瓜的边界地带。他们将在当地印第安人中争取支持。然后他们将向内陆挺进。他们将沿着圣胡安河穿过丛林，占领这个西班牙堡垒。从那里，他们将一路进发——沿着河流穿过丛林，占领这个西班牙堡垒，从那里，他们将
captain, but will do in due course. And there's a sense in which over the course of Nelson's career, Collingwood is always just behind him. He is with his dog. With his dog bounce. And in fact, at Trafalgar, Collingwood will command one of the two columns. He will indeed. Alongside Nelson. So worth mentioning him at this point. So Nelson is now given a ship called the Hinchinbrook, a 28 gun frigate. It is his own ship. What an amazing moment this is for him to be piped onto the ship for the first time
一路到达太平洋，在太平洋建立一个基地，并且他们或许能够拦截来自利马的西班牙珍宝船队。这是一种看着地图时觉得非常棒的计划。是的。你知道的，在金斯顿的军官食堂里或者别的什么地方。正是如此。等你到了那里，发现到处都是蚊子和蛇，那就太糟糕了。
as the captain. But his life almost ends at this point because he, as you suggested earlier Tom, he goes on an incredibly harebrained and foolhardy expedition. I think it's fair to say that whenever Nelson goes anywhere on land. If it goes wrong. Yeah. Disaster is not far away. Yeah. So the governor of Jamaica has this mad scheme. This British force will land on the Mosquito coast, which is on the sort of borderland of Honduras and Nicaragua. They'll raise support among the local Indians. Then they will strike inland. They'll go up the San Juan river through the jungle, seize this Spanish fort. From there, they'll go all the way to River through the jungle, sees this Spanish fort from there, they'll
确实如此。而这正是发生的实际情况。于是他们出发了。纳尔逊即使在1780年初出发时，也感到有些焦虑，因为他们带的部队，即士兵们基本上都是衣衫褴褛的。他们当中有一半人完全被朗姆酒或者别的什么东西喝废了。所以他们看起来就像海盗。他们到达了圣胡安河。天气异常炎热闷潮。正如你所说，到处都是蛇和凯门鳄。是的，有一个著名的片段，当地的印第安领袖对纳尔逊印象深刻，因为事实证明他整晚都和一条剧毒的蛇依偎在一起。他某种程度上站起身来，把毯子一掀，那条蛇就飞了出去。
go all the way to the Pacific, that establish a base on the Pacific and they might be able to intercept the treasure fleets from Lima. It's the kind of plan that looks very good when you're with a map. Yeah. You know, in the officer's mess in Kingstown or something. Exactly. When you get there and you find there are just mosquitoes and snakes everywhere, it's terrible.
结果他们觉得他注定成就伟大。这非常亚历山大大帝，不是吗？难道不是吗？总之，他们到达了这座西班牙堡垒。他们意识到——结果，这非常亚历山大大帝，不是吗？难道不是吗？总之，他们到达了这座西班牙堡垒，他们意识到，哦，我们只带了一半的炮弹。真是个灾难。它们全在河口或者别的什么地方。好吧，不管怎样，我们还是攻打一下这个堡垒吧。
Exactly. And this is precisely what happens. So they set off. Nelson, even as they set off in early 1780, he's a little bit anxious because the troops, the soldiers they're taking are basically all ragged. Half of them are absolutely wasted on rum or something. So they look like pirates. They get to the San Juan River. It's incredibly hot and muggy. As you said, there's snakes and caimans everywhere. Yeah, there's a famous bit where the local Indian leaders are very impressed with Nelson because it turns out he spent all night snuggled up with an incredibly poisonous snake. He kind of stands up and throws out his blanket and the snake goes flying.
结果他们被困在这个堡垒下方的沼泽里。随后热病开始肆虐。英国士兵的脸色 literalmente 变成了黄色。所以纳尔逊现在因为黄热病而面色蜡黄。他病得连帐篷都出不去。他很可能会死，因为剧透一下，2000名顺着那条河行军的人中，十分之九的人都死了，两千五百人被抛弃在那里，而且完全是白白送命。
And they feel that he's destined for greatness as a result. That's very Alexander the Great, isn't it? Isn't it? So anyway, they get to this Spanish fort. They realise a result. That's very Alexander the Great, isn't it? Isn't it? So anyway, they get to this Spanish fort, they realize, oh, we only brought half the cannonballs. What a disaster. They're all the way back in the mouth of the river or whatever. Well, we'll have a crack at the fort anyway.
就在这时，发生了一个不可思议的运气转折。负责加勒比海事务的帕克海军上将说，其实我希望纳尔逊回到牙买加。我要派科林伍德去接管“欣钦布鲁克”号。所以，没错。这就是科林伍德沿着纳尔逊的足迹前进，踏着纳尔逊的足迹。是的。
And they get stuck in this swamp underneath this fort. Fever then takes hold. The British literally turn yellow. So Nelson is now bright yellow with yellow fever. He's too sick to leave his tent. He's probably going to die because spoiler alert out of 2,000 men who sail up that river, nine out of 10 of them die left behind two and a half thousand men and for absolutely nothing.
所以基本上纳尔逊被解除职务并奉命返回牙买加，但他病得无法走路。他算是被抬回船上返回牙买加的，他一路回到了皇家港，他病得极其严重，真的濒临死亡，他受到了一位朋友的女管家的照顾，那是一位名叫古巴的获得自由的黑人女性。据说她精通医术。古巴基本上把从死神手里把他拉了回来。如果没有古巴，我想他早就死了。1780年夏末，一位医生来给他做了检查，诊断他患有胆汁性呕吐、神经性头痛、内脏阻塞以及许多其他身体虚弱的症状。我的意思是，你肯定不希望得这些病，对吧？
And then there's an incredible stroke of luck. Admiral Parker, who's in charge in the Caribbean says, I actually want Nelson back in Jamaica. I'm going to send Collingwood to take over the Hinchinbrook. So, right. So that's Collingwood following in Nelson's footsteps, Nelson's footsteps. Yeah.
你绝对不想得这些。而且医生实际上说，听着，他不能呆在加勒比海了。他必须回英国。否则他真的会死。这很像他从印度回来的时候，对吧？嗯，同样的事情再次发生了。每当纳尔逊生病并且不得不进行长途航行时，爱国主义的光芒就会重新燃起。
So basically Nelson is relieved and ordered back to Jamaica and he's too ill to walk. He's kind of carried back to the ship to go back to Jamaica. And he goes all the way back to Port Royal and he's too ill to walk, he's kind of carried back to the ship to go back to Jamaica, and he goes all the way back to Port Royal. And he's extremely ill on the verge of death really, and he is cared for by a friend's housekeeper who is called Cuba, who is a black freed woman. And she's supposed to have had kind of skill with medicine. And Cuba basically nurses him back to life. Without Cuba, he would have died, I think. A doctor came and examined him in the late summer of 1780 and diagnosed bilious vomitings, nervous headaches, visceral obstructions, and many other bodily infirmities. I mean, you don't want that, do you?
嗯，上帝对他说话了。是的。上帝选择了让他为国家服务。而且我认为他对此坚信不疑，简直是字面上的坚信。他一生都觉得，你知道的，他正被一种富有远见的、先知般的炽热感所召唤，他将这种炽热感与上帝联系在一起，并认为上帝是他的向导。上帝召唤了他，在他给我们留下的所有信件中，那些发送给海军部的信件以及他的通信中，如果你把它们与其他军阶相似的人写信进行比较，纳尔逊要比他的任何同僚都更乐于向上帝祈求。
You definitely don't want that. And the doctor actually said, look, he can't stay here in the Caribbean. He's got to go back to England. Otherwise, he really will die. Very like when he comes back from India, isn't it? Well, the same thing happens again. Whenever Nelson is ill and has to go on a long voyage, the glow of patriotism returns.
有趣的是，我前几天读到一件事：总是提到上帝，却从不提及耶稣或基督。总是提到全能者。没错，因为耶稣是个失败者。是的。但上帝嘛，你知道的，上帝会降下惩罚之类的话。正是如此。烈火之柱。正是如此。我说了他的这种感觉具有先知色彩。
Well, God speaks to him. Yes. God has chosen him to serve his country. And he believes this, I think, absolutely literally. He feels all his life that he is, you know, he's being summoned by this kind of this visionary, this prophetic sense of fire, which he associates with God and that God is his guide. God has called him and in all his letters, which we have, which are sent to the Admiralty in his correspondence, and you can compare them with other letters written by people of similar rank. Nelson is far readier to invoke God than any of his peers.
纳尔逊宣告自己是一位先知，纳尔逊终将成为一名海军上将。我将会康复，我关于荣耀的梦想终将实现。哦，我太喜欢这个了。于是他病好了。他最终被送回了北美，并在1783年协助撤离纽约，当时忠于英国的保皇派正在撤离。汤姆，你当然会看到，成千上万逃亡的奴隶被他们的英国朋友营救并带往北方，
Interestingly, I was reading a thing the other day, always God, never ever Jesus or Christ. It's always the Almighty. No, because Jesus is a loser. Yeah. But God's, you know, God's smites and all that kind of thing. Exactly. Pillars of fire. Exactly. I said his sense is prophetic.
越过边界前往加拿大重获自由。所以这对纳尔逊和所有人来说都是个好消息。他有一段时间一直在阻止美国船只从——我想大概是波士顿港——驶出。是的，正是如此。有很多海上封锁，我刚才跳过了这部分。他的船员开始患上坏血病。从本质上讲，纳尔逊，他经验不足，没有提前做好计划。这给他上了一课至关重要的教训，那就是船上绝对需要有定期的水果供应。这也是纳尔逊身上确实需要强调的一个方面，即他不仅擅长战斗，他也同样擅长筹备。
Nelson proclaims in a prophet, Nelson will yet be an Admiral. I shall recover and my dream of glory be fulfilled. Oh, I love it. So he gets better. He's eventually sent back to North America and he assists in the evacuation of New York where the loyalists are being evacuated in 1783. He would have seen, of course, Tom, the thousands of escaped slaves who were being rescued by their British friends and taken north
他在这一点上非常出色，是的。从那时起，他将确保他指挥的船只始终有充足的水果供应。正是如此。实际上，如果人们在本系列结束后对纳尔逊产生了足够的兴趣，想要阅读诸如世界上出版的最长的书——也就是约翰·萨格登的《纳尔逊传》——里面有大量关于订购青柠的细节。这绝对令人着迷，因为这是皇家海军远远领先于世界上任何其他同类组织的一个方面。这可以被看作是亚马逊未来能够为你寄送一个插头或什么的雏形，我想是这样的。是的。我的意思是，这一切正是从这里开始的。补给委员会或无论它叫什么名字，是当时存在过的同类机构中最优秀的一个。因为没有这些，船只就无法坚持。
of the border to Canada and to freedom. So that's great news for Nelson and for everybody. He has a spell where he's been stopping American ships from coming out, I think, from Boston Harbor, perhaps. Yeah, exactly. There's a lot of blockading, which I've skipped over. And his crew start going down with Scurvy. And essentially Nelson is, he's been inexperienced and he hasn't planned ahead. And this teaches him a crucial lesson that you absolutely need to have regular supplies of fruit on board. And this is one aspect of Nelson that really needs emphasizing is that he's not just about the fighting, he's also about the preparation.
正是如此。数周、数月甚至数年在海上航行。正是如此。所以他从美国战役中得到的最大收获是，他遇到了塞缪尔·胡德海军上将（Admiral Samuel Hood），一个和纳尔逊一样的牧师之子。战役。你看，他遇到了塞缪尔·胡德海军上将，一个像纳尔逊一样的牧师之子。胡德是另一位主张“你知道的，我们需要发展一种新型的海军战事，直接向敌人航行”的人。猛烈进攻，全力冲击，彻底歼灭，彻底胜利。所以这又是纳尔逊战争意识形态中的又一块基石，如果你愿意这么称呼的话。战争结束了。他回到了家。他现在是一名船长了。他有了一位强大的恩人，胡德海军上将。胡德海军上将把他引见给了乔治三世，这太棒了。他去了法国，不是吗？他去那里表面上是为了学习语言，而这显然失败了。他和
He's brilliant at this, yeah. And from that point on, he will ensure that the ships that he commands always have enough supplies of fruit. Exactly. And actually, if people are sufficiently interested in Nelson after the series to want to read like the world's longest ever books published, which are John Sugden's Titanic Lies of Nelson. There's enormous quantity of stuff in there about the ordering of limes. And it's absolutely fascinating because this is a way in which the Royal Navy are way in
一个朋友坐着邮船去了加来，说句公道话，法国的乡村给他留下了深刻的印象。他说，这是一个非常漂亮的国家，但他对两件事感到震惊。对旅馆吗？是的，对法国人的热情好客，他认为那简直糟透了。他住过一家旅馆，他说在英国我们会认为这简直是猪圈，但在法国他们却觉得这，你知道的，这是雷尚托酒店之类的。另一件事是法国贫富之间的巨大差距。
advance of any other comparable organisation anywhere in the world. And it's a prefiguring, I suppose, of Amazon's ability to send you a plug or something. I guess so. Yeah. I mean, this is where it's beginning. The victualling board or whatever it's called is the best of its kind that's ever existed at this point. Because without that, the ships can't stay. Exactly. For weeks and months and often years at sea.
你看到了吗？是的，我看到了。所以那里没有像纳尔逊本人那样的中间阶层。他说法国只有极其富有和极其贫穷的人。我其实并不确定这是真的，因为这与我们在法国大革命系列节目开头所说的话略有矛盾。但这可能确实符合纳尔逊的视角。
Exactly. So the big thing he gets from the American campaign is he meets Admiral Samuel Hood, a Vicar's son like Nelson. campaign. You see he meets Admiral Samuel Hood, a vicar son like Nelson. Hood is another one of these people who are saying, you know, we need to develop a new kind of naval warfare to sail straight at the enemy. Going hard, going hard, total annihilation, total victory. So again, another building block in Nelson's sort of ideology of war, if you like. The war is over. He comes home. He's now a captain. He's got a powerful patron, Admiral Hood. Admiral Hood introduces him to George III, which is great. He goes off to France, doesn't he? He goes there to learn the language, ostensibly, which he signally fails. He goes with
没错。所以他从美国战役中获得的最大收获是，他遇到了塞缪尔·胡德海军上将，一个和纳尔逊一样的牧师之子。战役。你看，他遇到了塞缪尔·胡德海军上将，一个和纳尔逊一样的牧师之子。胡德是又一个主张我们需要发展一种新型海军战术、直接向敌人航行的人。猛烈进攻，猛烈进攻，彻底消灭，彻底胜利。所以这又是纳尔逊战争意识形态中的一个构建块，如果你愿意的话。战争结束了。他回到了家。他现在是一名船长了。他有一个强大的赞助人，胡德海军上将。胡德海军上将把他引见给乔治三世，这太棒了。他去了法国，不是吗？他去那里表面上是为了学习语言，但他显然失败了。他和一个
a friend on the packet boat to Calais and he is impressed, to be fair to him, by the French countryside. He says, very handsome country, but he's appalled by two things. By the inns? Yeah, by French hospitality, which he thinks is terrible. He stayed in one inn and he said in England we would consider this a pigsty, but in France they think this is, you know, it's Rue L'Enchateau hotel or something. And the other thing is the gap between the rich and poor in France.
朋友坐邮船去了加来，说句公道话，他对法国的乡村印象深刻。他说，这是一个非常美丽的国家，但他对两件事感到震惊。客栈吗？是的，他对法国的热情好客感到震惊，他认为这糟透了。他住过一家客栈，他说在英国我们会认为这是个猪圈，但在法国他们却觉得这是什么吕兰沙托酒店之类的。另一件事是法国贫富之间的巨大差距。
Did you see this? Yeah, I did. So there's no middling group of people such as Nelson himself. He says there's between the rich and poor in France. See this? Yeah, I did. So there's no middling group of people such as Nelson himself. He says there's only very rich and very poor. I'm not actually sure that's true because that slightly contradicts what we were saying at the beginning of the French Revolution series. But it might be true to Nelson's perspective.
你看到这个了吗？是的，我看到了。所以没有像纳尔逊本人这样的中间阶层。他说法国只有极富和极穷的人。我其实不太确定这是否属实，因为这与我们在法国大革命系列节目开始时所说的话略有矛盾。但这可能符合纳尔逊的视角。
I think it's true that he thinks it anyway, should we put it that way. And then, you know, what's he going to do in peacetime? Peacetime is always quite boring. And actually, what is worse, he is given what he clearly regards as a terrible job. He is sent back to the Caribbean to patrol against smuggling. But Dominic, just to say, I mean, it is a terrible job, but it's better than being stuck at half pay back at home. Of course it is. So in that sense, it's a marker of, you know, that he's still in the running for promotion. Exactly. That's absolutely true. Cause he could have course have been put, yeah, basically on the reserve list. Yeah. Kind of moldering. So he goes back to the Caribbean. His job is basically to stop the plantation owners in
我想他心里确实是那么想的，如果我们要这么说的话。然后，你知道他在和平时期要做什么？和平时期总是挺无聊的。而且实际上，更糟糕的是，他被派去干了一件他显然认为是很糟糕的差事。他被送回加勒比海去巡逻打击走私。但是多米尼克，我是说，这确实是个糟糕的差事，但总比在家里拿半薪闲着强。当然是这样。所以从这个意义上说，这标志着他仍然在竞争晋升的行列中。没错。这绝对是真的。因为他本可以被列入预备役名单。是的。有点在发霉。所以他回到了加勒比海。他的工作基本上是阻止那里的种植园主
the Caribbean trading for cheap American goods, which they now have a taste for, but which are prohibited since the peace with the rebel colonists. The Navigation Act. He hates the plantation owners. He says they're trash because they're smuggling and he thinks this is very unpatriotic of them. However, on one of these islands, the island of Nevis, he makes a friend called John Richardson Herbert who is the president of the local council. Herbert agrees with him about this clampdown on smuggling. They become friends, you know, Nelson is always looking for kind of an older man to be a kind of
在加勒比海交易廉价的美国商品，他们现在对这种商品很感兴趣，但自从与叛军殖民者讲和后，这些商品就被禁止了。航海条例。他讨厌种植园主。他说他们是垃圾，因为他们在走私，他认为这非常不爱国。然而，在其中一个岛屿尼维斯岛上，他交了一个朋友叫约翰·理查森·赫伯特，他是当地议会的议长。赫伯特在打击走私这一点上与他意见一致。他们成了朋友，你知道的，纳尔逊总是希望有一个年长的人来扮演
father figure to him and Herbert plays this role for a bit. And one day, so the story goes, he meets a little boy playing under the table, this little boy at Herbert's house, and Nelson sort of says, who are you? And this boy says, oh, I'm Josiah. And then this woman comes in and this is a woman in her mid twenties called Fanny, who is Josiah's mother. She's Herbert's niece. Her husband, who was a doctor has died and left her a widow, a single mother with this little boy, and she's come back to live with her uncle on Nevis. She's a very, very sweet person. Isn't she Fanny? She plays
父亲的角色，赫伯特暂时扮演了这个角色。有一天，据故事所说，他在桌子底下遇到一个小男孩，这个小男孩在赫伯特家里，纳尔逊就问，你是谁？这个男孩说，哦，我是若西亚。然后这个女人进来了，这是一个二十多岁的中年妇女，名叫范妮，是若西亚的母亲。她是赫伯特的侄女。她的丈夫是一名医生，已经去世了，留她守寡，是一个带着这个小男孩的单身母亲，她回到尼维斯跟叔叔一起生活。她是一个非常非常温柔的人。不是吗，范妮？她会弹
the piano. Kind, solicitous, gentle. Yeah. She speaks French. She paints watercolours. She's just a lovely person. She's perhaps if you were being harsh, you would say a little bit bland. Is that harsh Tom? A little bit wet. A bit wet maybe. I think of her as a kind of Dickensian. The kind of woman that a Dickens hero would end up marrying and wouldn't be as fun as all the grotesques that you've met over the course of the novel. Exactly. A kind woman who's supportive of her husband, but basically has nothing to say for herself.
钢琴。善良、体贴、温和。是的。她会说法语。她画水彩画。她只是一个可爱的人。如果你说得苛刻一点，你可能会说她有点平淡。这样说苛刻吗，汤姆？有点无趣。也许有点无趣。我把她看作狄更斯式的人物。狄更斯小说里的男主角最终会娶的那种女人，但她不会像你在小说中遇到的那些怪咖那样有趣。没错。一个支持丈夫的好女人，但基本上没有什么个性可言。
Yeah. And actually on the subject of grotesques, because they end up getting married. They do. In 1787. And the man who gives away, gives her away and is the witness at the wedding is none other than a royal prince, William Henry, who will go on to become the sailor king, William the fourth in due course. And he's an absolute lout. He's a terrible man. And he's basically, it's a tricky gig for Nelson because he's been appointed to serve as chaperone really to William. And William is useless.
是的。事实上说到那些怪咖，因为他们最后结婚了。他们确实结了婚。在1787年。而牵着新娘的手并将她交出去、并在婚礼上担任证婚人的人，不是别人，正是王室王子威廉·亨利，他日后将成为水手国王威廉四世。他绝对是个粗人。他是个糟糕的家伙。基本上，这对纳尔逊来说是个棘手的差事，因为他被指派去真正担任威廉的随从。而威廉一无是处。
He's trapped because Nelson himself is a kind of very reserved man. He's not a man who enjoys kind of necking entire barrels of port and then flogging his crew. You know, he likes a cup of tea of an afternoon, but at the same time, you know, this is a prince and Nelson is a royalist. So he's completely torn and he's essentially been appointed by his superiors, including Admiral Hood to try and keep the prince on the straight and narrow. And Nelson doesn't feel able to do this. And it's the one kind of blot. It's the one time where he damages his career, I think. And his superiors start kind of thinking, oh, we're not sure about
他被困住了，因为纳尔逊本人是一个非常内向的人。他不是那种喜欢狂饮整桶波特酒然后鞭笞船员的人。你知道的，他喜欢在下午喝杯茶，但与此同时，你知道，这是一个王子，而纳尔逊是个保王党。所以他内心备受煎熬，他基本上是被他的上司，包括胡德海军上将指派来，试图让这位王子走正道。而纳尔逊觉得自己无力做到这一点。这是唯一的瑕疵。这是他损害自己职业生涯的一次经历，我认为。他的上司们开始觉得，哦，我们对
him. That's right, because the Admiralty are very cross with Nelson. They say you were told to keep William Henry in check and to stop him flogging people and shouting and being sick everywhere and stuff. And actually he's totally disgraced himself in the Caribbean and it's all your fault. And Nelson, because he's deferential and hierarchical, he doesn't know what to do. He can't bring himself to discipline William Henry. And also, Dominic, just to say that all this stuff with the smugglers, I mean, again, it would have been easier for Nelson to just leave that because he's making enemies, some
他不太确定。没错，因为海军部对纳尔逊非常生气。他们说，你被告知要管束威廉·亨利，阻止他鞭打别人、大喊大叫、到处呕吐之类的。而实际上他在加勒比海彻底身败名裂，这都是你的错。而纳尔逊，因为他恭顺且注重等级制度，他不知道该怎么办。他无法狠下心来惩罚威廉·亨利。而且，多米尼克，我得说，所有这些关于走私的事情，我是说，对纳尔逊来说，直接不管这些其实会更容易，因为他正在树敌，其中
of whom are in the Royal Navy itself. Yes, exactly. So it's a bad time for him, I think. Now, William Henry says to everybody, oh, she'll be a wonderful match for Horatio. She's a pretty girl, sensible girl. Pretty filly. I'm sure he won't repent the step he's taken. But actually everybody else says, I think he probably will repent
一些人甚至就在皇家海军内部。是的，完全如此。所以对他来说，这是一个糟糕的时期，我认为。现在，威廉·亨利对每个人都说，哦，她会是霍雷肖的绝配。她是个漂亮的女孩，懂事的女孩。漂亮的姑娘。我确信他不会后悔自己做出的决定。但实际上其他人都在说，我想他可能会后悔
the step he's taken because they're such temperamental opposites. Now Nelson's love life in later episodes, when we could do the second season of Nelson in the spring, which we will, you will see that the issue with Fanny is basically that they should probably never have got married in the first place. She does not have any understanding of what I might call it the slightly histrionic quality in Nelson's character. She's a sweet person though. She is. I very much team Fanny. She is and when she comes back to England she will look after Nelson's elderly father. You know she will be like a daughter to him. She will indeed because this is what happens they come home later that year, 1787, they've got Josiah in tow. Poor Josiah, he's not a brilliant person actually, I don't know
他做出的决定，因为他们的性格截然相反。现在说到纳尔逊的感情生活，在以后的剧集里，当我们可以做纳尔逊第二季时，也就是春天的时候，我们会的，你会发现，关于范妮的问题，基本上是他们当初可能根本就不该结婚。她根本无法理解我所谓的纳尔逊性格中那种略带戏剧化的特质。不过她是个温柔的人。她确实是。我非常支持范妮。她确实是，当她回到英国后，她会照顾纳尔逊年迈的父亲。你知道的，她会像女儿一样对待他。她真的会这样，因为事情就是这样的，他们在那年晚些时候，即1787年回到了家，带着若西亚。可怜的若西亚，他其实并不是个才华横溢的人，我不知道
why I'm feeling sorry for him. He's a bit of an oaf himself. But they send him off to boarding school and then they go back to Burnham Thorpe to Norfolk to live with the Reverend Edmund Nelson. So he's doddering around thinking about sermons. Fanny arrives and she keeps house very well. So she and Edmund actually become the very best of friends and they're talking about sermons and she's doing a kind of embroidering or something and talking to the servants. She loves it. That's what she wants. Yeah. Shall we, my dear, go and see the birds? Exactly. That kind of thing. Exactly. But Nelson is bored out of his mind. He reads the paper, he digs the garden, he goes hair coursing, which is sort of hunting. And he comes back and he says, Oh, I didn't enjoy that. By this point, it's 1788. And in September,
为什么我要同情他。他自己也有点像个呆子。但他们把他送去寄宿学校，然后他们回到诺福克的伯纳姆索普去和埃德蒙·纳尔逊牧师一起生活。所以他整天糊里糊涂地想着布道的事。范妮来了，她把家务操持得很好。所以她和埃德蒙实际上成了最好的朋友，他们谈论布道，她做着刺绣之类的事情，还跟仆人们聊天。她喜欢这样。这正是她想要的。是的，亲爱的，我们要不要去看看鸟？没错。就是那种事。没错。但纳尔逊无聊透顶。他看报纸，在花园里挖土，去玩野兔Coursing（一种狩猎活动）。他回来后说，哦，我一点也不喜欢这样。到这个时候，已经是1788年了，在9月份，
he turns 30. And in 1788, he must be thinking, you know, my career is finished. The only thing that could conceivably come to my rescue would be a major convulsion in European affairs. But it's 1788, what could possibly happen? So summer 1789, we can surmise that Nelson one day opened the Norfolk bugle or whatever and read to his horror shenanigans in France of seditious and subversive behaviour on the streets of Paris. Now the thing is, Nelson has been primed to dislike the French by his mother.
他迎来了30岁生日。在1788年，他一定在想，你知道的，我的职业生涯结束了。唯一可能拯救我的，就是欧洲事务发生重大动荡。但现在是1788年，究竟能发生什么事呢？所以到了1789年夏天，我们可以推测，纳尔逊有一天打开《诺福克号角报》或别的什么报纸，惊恐地读到法国巴黎街头发生了煽动性和颠覆性的叛乱活动。问题是，纳尔逊的母亲从小就灌输了他对法国人的厌恶。
He thinks the French are Britain's enemies. He's been to France, he thought it was terrible, the very poor quality of Inns, all of that. But what is more ideologically he is primed to dislike everything about the French Revolution. Nelson, as you read out that passage Tom, King and country is what fires him and he never ever questions it. There's a famous comment that he supposedly makes, it's possibly apocryphal, but it's very famous, that he supposedly told a young midshipman, first, you must always obey orders, secondly, you must consider every man as your enemy who speaks ill of your king, and thirdly,
他认为法国人是英国的敌人。他去过法国，他认为那里糟透了，旅店质量极差，诸如此类。但更重要的是，从意识形态上讲，他天然就反感法国大革命的一切。纳尔逊，正如你刚才朗读的那段话，汤姆，国王与国家是激励他的动力，他从未对此有过任何质疑。有一个著名的说法据说出自他之口，虽然可能是杜撰的，但非常有名，据说他曾对一名年轻的海军见习生说：第一，你必须永远服从命令；第二，你必须把每个说你国王坏话的人都视为你的敌人；第三，
you must hate a Frenchman as you do the devil. And I think the reason why this reverberates, even if it's apocryphal, is that it does kind of sum up Nelson's sense of morality really, because we've talked about his sense of a beneficent hierarchy, a paternalistic hierarchy, but that obeying orders, I mean, that would include obeying the orders that you get from God. So it's resonance with his deep sense of piety. You must consider every man as your enemy who speaks ill of your king. I mean, Nelson, like, you know, a huge majority of people in Britain generally views the British constitution with its neutered monarchy, its balance of powers as the best constitution that there could possibly be.
你必须像恨魔鬼一样恨法国人。我认为这段话之所以能引起共鸣，即使它是杜撰的，是因为它确实概括了纳尔逊的道德观，因为我们讨论过他那种仁慈的等级观念、家长式的等级观念，而服从命令——这意味着包括服从上帝的命令。所以这与他深厚的虔诚感产生了共鸣。你必须把每个说你国王坏话的人都视为你的敌人。我是说，纳尔逊，就像英国绝大多数人一样，总体上将英国宪法——及其虚君共和制和权力制衡——视为可能存在的最好的宪法。
And one that every other country, including the French, would benefit from adopting. And of course there are lots of people in France who agree with that, actually. Yeah. Mirabeau and people like that in the revolution. Yeah. So Nelson absolutely sees he wouldn't be loyal to a king who was a tyrant. He's loyal to a king who serves as a symbol of what Nelson sees as the best constitution you could possibly have. Which of course George III does pretty well, I would say. Yeah, he does it fine. I mean, partly by being mad.
并且认为其他所有国家，包括法国，都会从中受益。当然，法国也有很多人实际上赞同这一点。是的。革命中的米拉波之流。是的。所以纳尔逊绝对明白，他不会忠于一个暴君国王。他效忠的是这样一个国王：他象征着纳尔逊眼中所能拥有的最好宪法。乔治三世当然把这一点做得相当不错，我要说。是的，他做得很好。我是说，部分原因是他疯了。
But also his enthusiasm for farming, Tom, which I think is always very endearing. That as well. And then thirdly, you must hate a Frenchman as you do the devil. I mean, partly by being mad. But also his enthusiasm for farming, Tom, which I think is always very endearing. That as well. And then thirdly, you must hate a Frenchman as you do the devil. I mean, that is a sense, of course, that is then sharpened by the revolution. Exactly. Because Nelson correctly comes to see the revolution as a mortal threat to Britain's independence and to the constitution that Nelson admires so highly. Exactly.
但同样还有他对农业的热情，汤姆，我觉得这总是非常可爱。还有那个。然后第三，你必须像恨魔鬼一样恨法国人。我是说，这种感觉当然在革命后变得更加强烈了。没错。因为纳尔逊正确地认识到，革命是对英国独立以及纳尔逊如此高度赞赏的宪法的致命威胁。没错。
So Nelson is offstage in the early years of the revolution. We can only really surmise but you can imagine what he thinks when he reads about the flight of a Wren, the declaration of war, all the things that we covered. Well, Britain's not at war with France at this point. No, it's not. So he must have read all this and you can imagine that he regards this as a disapproval, but also mounting excitement, I would imagine, as he thinks Britain is going to be drawn into this, into this conflict. Because for an ambitious officer, the idea of a war with France, I mean, that is something to get the sort of blood flowing.
所以在革命的早期，纳尔逊并未参与其中。我们只能靠猜测，但你可以想象他在读到王室出逃、宣战以及我们所涵盖的所有事情时的想法。好吧，此时英国还没有与法国开战。不，还没有。所以他一定读了所有这些，你可以想象他认为这是一种非难，但同时我也能想象他的兴奋之情在不断高涨，因为他认为英国将被卷入这场冲突中。因为对于一个雄心勃勃的军官来说，与法国发生战争的想法，绝对是能让热血沸腾的事情。
By late 1792, as listeners to our French Revolution series will know, the Prussians and the Austrians have been beaten back. France is expanding. It is very clear that war is coming. And by December, the orders have basically gone out, the word has gone out, prepare for war. You know, war is coming. Because the King at this point is on trial in France and in due course is going to be sentenced to death.
到了1792年底，正如我们法国大革命系列的听众所知，普鲁士人和奥地利人已经被击退了。法国在扩张。战争即将来临，这一点非常清楚。到了12月，命令基本上已经下达，消息已经传开，准备战争。你知道，战争要来了。因为此时法国的国王正在受审，并且很快将被判处死刑。
Exactly. And will be executed in the early weeks of 1793. On the 6th of January 1793, Nelson is ordered to report the Admiralty and he is told, we have a ship for you. It is the 65 gun Agamemnon. And this is always his favourite ship, isn't it? It's always the one he looks back on with the fondest memories. Eggs and bacon, its crew called it because they always used to give them little kind
没错，并将在1793年初被处决。1793年1月6日，纳尔逊奉命向海军部报到，并被告知：我们为你准备了一艘船。那是装备了65门大炮的阿伽门农号。这一直是他的最爱，对吧？这总是他回首时带着最美好回忆的那艘船。水兵们称它为“培根鸡蛋”，因为他们总是喜欢给它起各种小
of nicknames because they didn't know how to pronounce classical terms. So they call it the eggs and bacon. On the 1st of February, France declares war on Britain on the 4th of February. And we are told in health and in great spirits, Nelson kisses Fanny goodbye and takes the coach South to Chatham and to war. And Dominic, they will not meet again for another four years. And when Nelson comes back, he will be a hero, but he will also be severely maimed. So what we've got to come, the battles of Cape St.
绰号，因为他们不会发古典术语的音。所以他们叫它培根鸡蛋。2月1日，法国对英国宣战，时间是2月4日。据说纳尔逊在身体健康、精神抖擞的状态下，吻别了范妮，坐上南下的马车前往查塔姆去迎接战争。多米尼克，他们将有四年时间不会再相见。当纳尔逊回来时，他将成为一个英雄，但也将会遭受严重的残疾。所以接下来我们要讲的是，圣文森特角战役
Vincent and Tenerife, the hunt for Napoleon and the Titanic showdown of the battle of the Nile. Tom, what can people do if they want to hear those right now? Well, if you want to show the kind of Nelsonian spirit of initiative and dash, you can go to therestishistory.com and you can join our jolly jack tars there. Sign up. Until next time, goodbye. Huzzah! Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和特内里费海战，对拿破仑的追捕，以及尼罗河战役的终极对决。汤姆，如果人们现在就想听到这些，该怎么做呢？好吧，如果你想展现出纳尔逊式的首创精神和冲劲，你可以访问 therestishistory.com，加入我们的快乐水手行列。注册吧。下次见，再见。乌拉！再见。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。